WILL ACT COMMITTEE WILL START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE BEING
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA.
AB.
THREE TEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AB THREE TWENTY NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND AB.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN ARE MCCARTY.
AND THE ITEMS.
I AB. ONE ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON IS BEING
PULLED OFF OF CONSENT.
AND THE OTHER ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
OUR ONE MOMENT [inaudible]
SEPARATE HERE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE OTHER.
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ARE.
AB THREE OH FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER. EIGHTY FOR TWENTY
FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AB
SIX TWENTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH IN AB SIX SIX TWO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
SO THOSE ARE THE CHANGES TO THE
AGENDA AND WE WILL BEGIN NOW
WITH SIMPLY MEMBER MARK STONE
ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS AB
FORTY FIVE IS A BILL THAT WOULD
REMOVE.
THE ABILITY FOR THE STATE AND
LOCAL JAIL STATE PRISONS AND
LOCAL JAILS IN CHARGE COPAYS AND
DURABLE MEDICAL.
HAS A GENESIS FROM LAST YEARS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO TRY AND
MAKE SURE THAT MEDICAL
PROVISIONS IN JAILS HAVE BEEN AS
CLEAR AS POSSIBLE WE WANT THINGS
WE DISCOVERED WAS CHARGING A
FIVE DOLLAR COPAY. FOR SOMEONE
WHO MAKES EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR
JUST IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES THAT OR HAVE ALREADY
ABANDON THE PRACTICE BECAUSE
THEY FOUNDED THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS FAR EXCEED.
THE THE COST TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM AND THE REALLY VERY
LITTLE BENEFITS.
TO CHARGING SOMEBODY A COPAY
LIKE WE LIKE WE DO OUT IN THE
REGULAR MARKET.
WHEN THEY ARE CAPTIVE IN PRISONS
WHEN THEY HAVE NO OTHER PLACE TO
GO AND IN FACT THAT THE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS IN EACH OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS WILL NOTE THAT
CHARGING THAT COPAY?
IS AN IMPEDIMENT TO INMATES
GETTING PROPER MEDICAL CARE THEY
WILL OFTEN WAIT UNTIL THE
PROBLEM BECOMES A CUTE.
N. WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
CHARGED A CO PAY IN ORDER TO GET
THE MEDICAL HELP THAT THEY NEED.
ACT WHEN TALKING WITH CDC ARE
ABOUT THIS THESE THESE THE
PRACTICE AS OF MARCH FIRST OF
THIS YEAR BECAUSE THEY REALIZE
THAT THIS WAS NOT.
SOMETHING THAT WAS WORKING THE
WAY THAT HAD ORIGINALLY BEEN
THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO WORK.
AND WHAT THE BILL BEFORE US DOES
IS REMOVE THE STATUE TO
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE
TO CHARGE COPAYS IN THE FUTURE.
AND APPLIES TO THE COUNTIES TO
LOCAL JAILS BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED GET THE MEDICAL
HELP THEY NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT
AS THEY NEED IT.
RATHER THAN HAVING TO WAIT AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I'VE.
THANK YOU AND YOU HAVE SOME
WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS RON MARYLAND RALSTON
AND I'M THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
PRIDE DEGREE BROWN A CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY FULLERTON.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS
THE HIGHER EDUCATION AND
SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION OF THE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
AND A LONG TIME MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS.
A GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION THAT
ADVOCATES FOR WOMEN.
GENDER NON CONFORMING AND TRANS
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA PRISONS.
AS WELL AS A FORM INCARCERATED
PERSON SENTENCED TO LIFE.
WHO SPENT TWENTY THREE YEARS AT
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR
WOMEN IN CORONA?
I AM HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY FIVE BY
SHARE MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF SOMEONE
WHO HAD TO ACCESS CARE.
AND AS AN ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE
WITH BARRIERS TO ACCESSING CARE.
LIKE MANY OF YOU DURING THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND NINETIES I
WITNESSED CALIFORNIA'S PRISON
POPULATION INCREASED BY 5100%.
ARRIVING AT THE PRISON AT AGE.
TWENTY FOUR THERE ARE WOMEN
HOUSE INTO PERSON SALES.
SLEEPING IN BOILER ROOM STAY
ROOMS. FOUR YEAS AND THE
AUDITORIUM.
THE SITUATION WITH AND HUMANE
AND UNHEALTHY.
INCARCERATED WOMEN WHO WERE NOT
RECEIVING THE PROPER CARE AND
WAREHOUSE AND DEFICIENT PRISON
CONDITIONS.
THEN PAROLE IN BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
ELIMINATING COPAYS IS GOOD FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH.
MOST WOMEN INTO THE PRISON
SYSTEM HAVING EXPERIENCED YEARS.
OF PHYSICAL MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
TRAUMA WITH LITTLE MEDICAL OR
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT WHILE
INCARCERATED [inaudible]
THEREFORE ACCESSING.
HEALTHCARE IS ESSENTIAL THIS
MEANS FREE HEALTHCARE.
WOMEN ARE THE MAJORITY OF
PRIMARY CARE GIVERS AND ONE
THING CAR SERRATED.
MOST FIND THEMSELVES WITHOUT
SOCIAL OR FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND
DEPENDED UPON THE STATE.
THIS IS MY SITUATION.
AS A MOTHER OF TWO BOYS THREE
AND FIVE YEARS OLD.
I DESPERATELY TRIED TO STAY IN A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM.
BUT DIDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO SO.
THROUGHOUT MY YEARS IN PRISON I
HELD MANY WORK IN VOCATIONAL
POSITIONS WHICH EARNED BETWEEN
ZERO PAY AND THIRTY SEVEN CENTS
AN HOUR.
HOWEVER MY AVERAGE.
EARNING CAPACITY WAS TWENTY TO
THIRTY SIX DOLLARS A MONTH. FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE A COPAY
REPRESENTS A DANGEROUS BAY AREA
TO ACCESS AND HEALTHCARE.
AND TO KEEPING FAMILIES TOGETHER.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH A CHRONIC ILLNESS
WHICH REQUIRED MORE OF IT IS TO
THE PRISON CLINIC AND LOCAL
HOSPITAL.
MANY TIMES WHILE IN PAIN I HAD
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THIN IN A
BIRTHDAY GIFT OR CHRISTMAS
PRESENT TO MY KIDS.
AND PURCHASING TOOTHPASTE
LAUNDRY SOAP OTHER PERSONAL CARE
ITEMS.
OR A GROWING MORE DEATH.
AS SOMEONE WITH AN AUTOIMMUNE
DISORDER.
I WAS ALWAYS SUSCEPTIBLE TO
COLDS AND SICKNESS.
SO EVEN THOUGH SEEKING A DOCTOR
WITH RISKY AND PUT MY HEALTH IN
DANGER I HAD TO DO IT.
MY LIFE MY SURVIVAL REQUIRED
CONSTANT CARE.
GOING TO THE DOCTOR IN PRISON IS
STRESSFUL.
THE MEANING AND STRIPS PEOPLE OF
THEIR HUMAN DIGNITY AND RIGHT TO
PRIVACY.
MANY TIMES I WAS SUBJECTED TO
GROUP STRIPS THIRTIETH DOING THE
EARLY HOURS OF THE MORNING.
AN ISOLATED AREAS OF THE PRISON.
SOME MAY ARGUE THAT ELIMINATING
COPAYS COULD LEAD TO ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO SEEK MEDICAL VISITS
FOR THE WRONG REASONS.
I NOR ANYONE I EVER KNEW DESIRE
TO STAND NAKED BEFORE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS.
AND OTHER INCARCERATED PEOPLE
LIFTING AND SEPARATING BODY
PARTS WHILE SICK AND IN PAIN.
JEFF TO GET OUT OF A JAIL SALE
OR A PRISON DOOR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
APOLOGIES BEFORE WE HEAR FROM
THE NEXT WITNESS SOMEONE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM OKAY.
COULD YOU DO ROLL CALL SKINNER.
HERE MORE LIKE PRESENT OR LUCK
HERE BRADFORD YOU'RE RIGHT FOR
YOUR JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE
MITCHELL.
MORALE -- OUT HERE WINNER.
I'M WILL GO.
WE HAVE A MOTION NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S JOSEPH CALDERON.
AND I'M A SENIOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER FOR THE
TRANSITIONS CLICK NETWORK I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FORTY FIVE THE TRANSITIONS
CLINIC NETWORK IS A NATIONAL
NETWORK OF MEDICAL HOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH CHRONIC
DISEASES RECENTLY RELEASED FROM
INCARCERATION.
FOUNDED ON THE IDEA THAT THE
PEOPLE CLOSEST TO THE PROBLEM
ARE CLOSEST TO THE SOLUTION.
AND EACH CLINIC ADOPTS THE
TRANSITIONS CLICK PROGRAM IN
PLACE A COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
WITH THE HISTORY FROM CAR
SERRATION AS A PART OF THE
CLINICAL TEAM.
BEING A MEDICAL EXPERT WORKING
WITH RETURNING COMMUNITY MEMBERS
I HAVE SEEN SAD STORIES ON WINE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE PASSED UP HEALTH
CARE TO PAY FOR BASIC
NECESSITIES LIKE TOTALLY TREASON
FOOD.
PEOPLE IN PRISON ARE AMONG THE
SICKEST MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY
PLEASE LET US KNOW THAT.
THEY HAVE HIGHER RATES OF
CHRONIC DISEASES HIGHER RATES OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AND 65285%
HAVE A HISTORY OF SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE USE.
AND ABUSE.
ON AVERAGE THERE ARE SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
RETURNING FROM PRISON MANY OF
WHOM HAD HIGH RATES OF CHRONIC
EN CAMINO WILL DISEASES AND
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO HEALTH
CARE.
WHICH EQUALS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
REQUIRING A COPAY FOR A CURSORY
PEOPLE PUTS THEIR HEALTH AT RISK.
MANY OF THE MEN AND WOMEN
RETURNING HOME FROM PRISON COME
FROM COMMUNITIES THAT
HISTORICALLY DID NOT HAVE HEALTH
CARE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH IN THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
BECAUSE THEY HEALTH INEQUITIES
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
I CAME FROM ONE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND THE ONLY THING I
KNOW ABOUT MEDICAL CARE WAS WITH
TO GET SHOTS FOR SCHOOL AND
WATCHED LOVED ONES DYING.
POVERTY TRAPS HEALTH IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
I UNDERSTAND PASSING UP TO
DOCTOR.
SO I CAN EAT.
BY ELIMINATING THE COPAY AB
FORTY FIVE WILL HELP IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAVOR SYSTEM
MONEY.
BY ADDRESSING THE MEDICAL ISSUES
EARLIER AS OPPOSED TO LATER BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY.
IT WILL SAVE LIVES.
I WATCHED PEOPLE DIE OF
TREATABLE DISEASES LIKE MY
FRIEND WHO TURNED GREEN AND WAS
WHEELED AWAY TO DIE BECAUSE OF
BAD POLICIES.
FAIR AND JUST ACCESS THE IS A
HUMAN RIGHT.
HEALTH CARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON A.
B. FORTY FIVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THEY CAN
COME UP TO THAT MIKE.
JUST INDICATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND YOUR THANK YOU
MORNING TIENE OF ARGUES THAT MAY
WHAT INITIATE JUSTICE CO SPONSOR
STRONG SUPPORT.
ERIC ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GLENN BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LESLIE CALDWELL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING YES MAN PALLID WITH
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
STEVEN WEBER CALIFORNIA ASKS ME
IN SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLY DRAU ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE BOYD WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I HAVE A GOOD REST ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL GLENDALE WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY CHAMBERS WITH ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT.
EMILY HARRIS OF ELLA BAKER
CENTER AND A HALF OF CURB
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE LEGIT IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN SUPPORT.
ALL THE RUMOR WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WITH THE COLLAPSE NECK OF THE
WELL STONE DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL
CLUB AND ALL OF BAKER CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
RICHARD MORALIS WITH THE PROP
ORGANIZATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS INDIA NOR.
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE ASIAN LAW CAUCUS AND
SURVIVOR PUNISHED COALITION AND
SUPPORT.
ALSO GIVE JUSTICE COALITION
LISA HOLDER EQUAL JUSTICE
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
HARD TO WE HAVE -- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
LET'S HAVE THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING MANAGER MEMBERS COREY
CELLS ALONG BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL RESPECTFULLY --
THERE IS NO DESIRE TO PREVENT OR
DENY MEDICAL CARE TO ANY INMATES --
IN THE BASIS OF OUR POSITION TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL THAT BEING SAID --
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT REMOVING
THE ABILITY NOT THE REQUIREMENT
BUT THE ABILITY TO CHARGE THIS
MODEST COPAY -- EVEN
UNDERSTANDING THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT YOU FOR DESCRIBED BY THE
WITNESSES I CAN SERVE AS A
DETERRENT TO FRIVOLOUS SEEKING
OF MEDICAL ATTENTION -- THERE
ARE EXISTING PROTECTIONS IN
STATUTE WITH WHICH WHICH WE
THINK.
STRIKE THE APPROPRIATE BALANCE
THE LOSS SAYS ALREADY NO PERSON
THAT YOU MAY NOT BE CHARGED IF
YOU DON'T HAVE FUNDS IN YOUR
ACCOUNT.
YOU MAY NOT BE DENIED CARE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE FUNDS THAT THE
MEDICAL PROVIDER IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES IS PERMITTED TO
WAIVE THE FEE.
AND ANY FOLLOW UP VISITS AT THE
DIRECTION OF THE MEDICAL
PROVIDER MUST BE PROVIDED
WITHOUT A FEE SO WE BELIEVE
THERE ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS IN
THE CASES WHERE THE FEE IS --
ALLOWED AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ASK YOU KNOW WHAT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT -- IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS YES SENATOR JACKSON --
THE NOTION WE PAY THESE PEOPLE
EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR IS REALLY
WERE I KIND OF WOULD LIKE TO GO
WITH THIS I DON'T WANT PEOPLE.
MAKING A COAL PAY IN ADDRESSING
WHEN I THINK OF FRANKLY PROBABLY
MORE PHANTOM ISSUES YOU KNOW.
THERE MAY BE LAWS THAT SAY THEY
HAVE PEOPLE IN PRISON AFTER WE
TAKE CARE BUT WE FOR TOO MANY
HORROR STORIES WHEN IT JUST
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THE QUESTION
IS WHY DON'T WE PAY PEOPLE --
I'M NOT SAYING IT TO PAYING
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
BUT EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR I MEAN
IN SOME INSTANCES NOTHING.
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO BUILD PEOPLE
UP SO THEY CAN FEEL GOOD ABOUT
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY GO BACK TO
SOCIETY THE NOTION.
THAT WE WE TELL YOU THE VET YOUR
VALUES EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR.
IS JUST I THINK.
VERY CONTRARY TO THE GOALS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE OF
ALLOWING PEOPLE AS THEY
EXPERIENCED LIFE INCARCERATED.
TO REFLECT UPON THE POTENTIALS
OF LIFE OUTSIDE OF PRISON AND TO
LET THEM KNOW WE VALUE THEIR
WORK.
MORE THAN EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR --
IN SO -- I'M GONNA COME IN AND
MOVE THIS BILL US IT'S ALREADY
BEEN MOVED BUT I I THINK WE'RE
LOOKIN AT THIS THE WRONG WAY I
THINK THESE PEOPLE.
WHO DO WORK SHOULD BE PAID AN
APPROPRIATE WAGE SO THAT IF THEY
ARE ASKED TO PAY A COPAY IT'S
COMMENSURATE WITH WHAT OTHERS IN
SOCIETY OR ASKED TO PAY -- UNTIL
THEY COULD AFFORD THAT.
RATHER THAN HAVE TO DECIDE THE
GOING TO WAIVE THEIR HEALTHCARE
SO THEY CAN GET A CHRISTMAS
PRESENT FOR THEIR KIDS THAT THEY
AREN'T ABLE TO SEE ANYWAY.
I THINK THIS WHOLE SYSTEM IS A
MESS.
AND I THINK THAT -- THE A AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
BILL BUT IT'S DEALING WITH THE
PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW KIND OF AS IT IS AND
MAYBE WHAT WE NEED TO DO GOING
FORWARD IS FIGURE OUT A WAY
WHICH THAT WERE THEORETICALLY
SAVING A LOT OF MONEY.
BY CLOSING DOWN THESE PRISONS
AND A REDUCING ARC ARE RUN --
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN OUR IN
OUR STATE PRISONS I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE MONEY'S GOING.
BUT CERTAINLY THE NOTION THAT.
WE PROVIDE PEOPLE EVEN IF IT'S
TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR -- SOMETHING
SO THAT IF WE'RE ASKING THEM TO
MAKE A CO PAY -- IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY CAN DO WITHOUT
WORRYING ABOUT WHETHER WHETHER
OR NOT THEY'RE GOING.
TO BE ABLE TO GET PERSONAL
HEALTH CARE PRODUCTS OR WHAT
HAVE YOU SO -- AGAIN OR NO
THAT'S NOT THIS BILL IN FRONT OF
US BUT THE NOTION THAT THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING TRUSTS FINE I
THINK IS JUST -- IT IS PATENTLY
FALSE PANDA AND I THINK THAT --
WE WE CAN A NEED TO DO BETTER IN
OUR STE IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THE PEOPLE RUNNING IT
HAVE TO TAKE A MORE HONEST.
AND MORE -- CREATIVE YOU ABOUT --
THE WAY WE CONDUCT THE OUR
PRISON SYSTEM BECAUSE IT'S AN
APP ABYSMAL FAILURE.
AND PERPETUATING THOSE SAME
THINGS I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO HELP US OVERCOME THAT SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK THANK YOU SENATOR MORE
LUCK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST AT THE LITTLE MAPS AND THE
NUMBER OF HOURS THAT SENATOR
JACKSON WORKS AND AND IT'S
PRETTY CLOSE TO EIGHT CENTS AN
HOUR [inaudible]
YOUR VOLUNTARY -- IN IN MY
ANALYSIS -- MISTER CELLS YELLOW
JUST MAYBE TO CONFIRM THERE'S NO
MANDATE TO CHARGE THE THREE
DOLLAR FEE.
IF THE INMATE CANNOT PAY THE FEE
THERE WILL BE NO FEE CHARGED.
AN INMATE SHALL NOT BE DENIED
MEDICAL CARE DUE TO THE LACK OF
FUNDS.
IN CASES OF AN INMATE MEDICAL
EMERGENCY NO FEE MAY BE IMPOSED.
FEES ARE FOR FEES FOR INMATE
FOLLOW UP VISITS ARE PROHIBITED.
AND ANY MONEY COLLECTED PURSUE
THIS BE IS SENT TO THE COUNTY
GENERAL FUND WHICH IS WHAT PAYS.
FOR SHERIFF'S.
DEPARTMENT ANYWAY TALK I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE'RE
FIXING IT THERE ARE THESE ALL
CORRECT.
YES THROUGH JR -- THOSE ARE ALL
THOSE PROVISIONS THAT YOU
ENUNCIATED ARE INCLUDED A PENAL
CODE SECTION FOUR ZERO POINT
FOUR ZERO ONE ONE POINT TWO TO
DESCRIBE THE PROVISIONS ON WHEN
THE C. MAY NOT BE CHARGED IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO PREVENT
FRIVOLOUS.
CASES OF COULD YOU.
ADDRESS THAT.
I'M WONDERING IF INSTEAD OF
ELIMINATING THE FEES SAID OKAY
YOUR FIRST VISIT.
IS FREE.
YOUR SECOND VISIT IS A DOLLAR
YOUR THIRD VISIT IS TO IN.
YOUR FEW FOURTH IS -- THREE SO
THAT YOU CAN.
STOP THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR IS IS
IS THAT.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE OR THROUGH
THE GERMAN SOMETHING WE'D BE
WILLING TO LOOK AT FOR SURE
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S NOT ABOUT
COLLECTING REVENUE ARE
PENALIZING SOMEONE WHO IS
SEEKING A MEDICAL VISIT.
IT IS AGAIN A TOOL THAT EXISTS
THAT IS NOT ALWAYS CHARGE AND IN
SOME CASES AS AS THE OTHER POINT
OUT.
THERE SOME COUNTIES DON'T CHARGE
THE FEE AND THEY MADE THAT
DECISION FOR WHATEVER REASON AS
YOU POINTED OUT IT'S NOT A
MANDATORY FEE AND SO AGAIN IT
EXISTS AS A TOOL THAT IS
AVAILABLE.
AND IF THAT SORT OF GRADUATED
FEE WERE TO BE DISCUSSED I THINK
WOULD BE MORE THAN WILLING TO
DISCUSS THAT SORT OF OPTION AND
THAT'S THE CHALLENGES.
WE HAVE MANY DIFFERENT VARIABLES
IN THE SYSTEM AND THIS IS JUST
ONE PIECE OF THAT AND THIS ONE
PIECE IS BEING ADDRESSED BY MANY
OTHER THINGS ARE BEING ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU -- CINNAMON STONE IS
THAT MAKES.
ERRORS THAT NOT [inaudible]
DEBATABLE NO THE END EVEN TO
SENATOR JACKSON'S COMMENT.
IF YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW
COPAYS WORK FOR US OUTSIDE.
IT'S MAKING SURE WE'RE PUTTING
SOME SKIN IN THE GAME WE HAVE A
MEDICAL VISIT THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THAT'S ABOUT.
WHEN YOU'RE INSIDE THAT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT CALCULATION BECAUSE NO
PLACE ELSE TO GO YOU DON'T HAVE
A CHOICE?
AND EVEN IF WE RAISE THE RATES
WHICH I WOULD AGREE EIGHT CENTS
AN HOUR IS IT.
IS A BIT EMBARRASSING THAT'S
WHERE THE STRUCTURE IS AN FOR
WILLING TO PUT A LOT OF MONEY
INTO IT.
IN FACT THE PRISON SYSTEM IS NOT.
WE'RE PUTTING MORE MONEY THE
PRISM YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR
BECAUSE OF INCREASING COSTS
WE'RE NOT YET CLOSING PRISONS
IT'S DIFFERENT TOPIC THAT SOME
THAT WE ULTIMATELY NEED TO DO.
BUT UNDER THE EXISTING SYSTEM.
EITHER WE FIND A WAY TO PAY
THESE FOLKS A LOT MORE IN THE
BUDGET WHICH WOULD BE VERY
EXPENSIVE AND I DON'T SEE THAT
COMING.
OR WE WE SORT OF SHIFT WHAT THE
WHAT THE INCENTIVES ARE IN THE
SHARES THAT I'VE TALKED.
TO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FRIVOLOUS MEDICAL VISITS.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY DATA
ABOUT WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS OR
HOW MANY PEOPLE COME FORWARD
WITH.
THEY CLAIM TO BE FRIVOLOUS
MEDICAL VISITS.
I'VE TOLD THEM THAT IF THIS
MOVES FORWARD AND THEY START
SEEING AN INCREASE IN THAT IF WE
CAN EVEN TO FIND IT I THINK
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS OTHER TOOLS
THAT THEY CAN USE. TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE.
THEY DO SAID CALLS THEY DO
TRIAGE THEY HAVE OTHER TOOLS AT
THEIR DISPOSAL BECAUSE THIS IS A
CAPTIVE POPULATION.
SO JUST FUNDAMENTALLY CHARGING
THEM ANYTHING FOR HEALTH CARE
DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY AND IT
PHILOSOPHICALLY I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD EVEN CONSIDER INSIDE EVEN
IF WE ADDRESS.
THE PRISON PAY.
AND THERE ARE OTHER MECHANISMS
THAT COULD BE PUT IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS THAT THIS THIS NOTION
THIS FEAR ABOUT ABOUT FRIVOLOUS
VISITS BUT I WILL ALSO TELL YOU
IN TALKING TO THE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS IN PRISONS AND IN
JAILS.
THEY DON'T SEE IT THE SAME WAY
AT ALL THEY SEE A CO PAY JUST AS
AN ABSOLUTE BARRIER AND THEY
DON'T SEE THAT THESE ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE TREATING THESE
PATIENTS.
THEY DON'T SEE THESE FRIVOLOUS
AS IT'S THEY DON'T THEY'RE
TELLING ME THAT THIS IS NOT.
A PROBLEM IN THEIR MINDS.
SO IF WE THINK THAT PUTTING A CO
PLACE IN PLACE A COPAY PLACE IS
GOING.
TO IS THE BARRIER TO THAT THE
FRIVOLOUS MEDICAL IT DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE THE CASE.
AND YET THERE'S NOT REALLY A
JUSTIFIABLE REASON FOR IT OTHER
THAN WE HAVE TO PAY ON THE
OUTSIDE YOU SHOULD PAID ON THE
INSIDE.
THAT KIND OF FALLS A LITTLE BIT
THIN GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THERE INSIDE AND AND WE'RE NOT.
SO THE WHOLE PHILOSOPHICAL THING
OF PUTTING THIS ON THEM.
BABY FEELS GOOD BABY CRITICISM
EVEN MORE WE HAVE TO DO IT SO
YOU HAVE TO DO IT.
BUT THOSE AREN'T RATIONAL HEALTH
REASONS THOSE AREN'T RATIONAL
POLICY REASONS WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE SYSTEM IS
FUNCTIONING AT YES BITS AND
PIECES AT A TIME.
BUT FUNCTIONING THE BEST THAT IT
CAN AND TAKING DOWN BARRIERS. TO
MEDICAL ACCESS.
SO I COME FROM A SUPERMAJORITY
BACKGROUND AND AB ONE OH NINE
SHOWS UP AND I THINK. TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN ONE OF THE THE
STAGGERING A REMARKABLE THINGS
THAT WE DISCOVERED IS HOW MANY
[inaudible]
INMATES.
WERE WERE BROUGHT DOWN TO THE
JAIL SYSTEM.
THAT HAD SEVERE MEDICAL ISSUES
ON WE WE FOUND OUR COSTS
INCREASED BECAUSE OF A SAID WE
HAD LIVER TRANSPLANTS AND ALL
KINDS OF ISSUES.
SO I CAN KIND OF SEE WHERE SOME
SERVICE ARE GOING TO SAY WAIT A
SECOND I WE'VE GOT.
TO MONITOR OUR COST SO THAT'S
SORT OF THE CONTEXT OF IT BUT
THE ONES LIKE SOME LARGER
COUNTIES LIKE SANTA CLARA THEY
HAVEN'T DONE THIS IN YEARS
BECAUSE THE COST OF
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM.
OUTWEIGH THE COSTS OF WHAT
THEY'RE COLLECTING SO AGAIN THEN
IT'S JUST BACK TO THE
PHILOSOPHICAL YOU DO A BECAUSE
WE DO IT.
I BROUGHT THIS UP WITH -- I'VE
THREE COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT
SO SANTA CLARA WAS ONE SANTA
CRUZ WAS MAKING ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND WHEN
I BROUGHT THIS UP TO THEM.
THEY THEIR GRUMBLING ABOUT IT
BUT THEY JUST STOP CHARGING
COPAYS THEY REALIZE THAT WAS A
LITTLE BIT SILLY MONTEREY HAS
PUSHED BACK A LITTLE BIT AND
THEIR CONCERN WAS EXACTLY THE
ISSUE ABOUT FRIVOLOUS.
VISITS AND THAT'S WHY I TALKED
THEM AND I COMMITTED TO THEM
THAT IF YOU ARE SEEING THAT SHOW
ME THE DATA LET'S TALK ABOUT
OTHER WAYS WE CAN DO AND IF I
CAN HELP.
I'M HAPPY TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PUTTING THINGS IN PLACE OR
ALLOWING THEM TO PUT PROCEDURES
IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO TRIAGE DID
THEY'RE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING.
INMATES INTO MEDICAL CARE
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT THOSE THE
MEDICAL BEDS FILLED UP FOR THOSE
DOCTORS BUSY WITH CASES THAT
THEY DON'T NEED TO SEE THAT'S
THAT'S A MEDICAL ISSUE AS WELL.
BUT AGAIN THE MEDICAL PROVIDERS
ARE TELLING ME BOTH OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL THE STATE LEVEL THAT'S NOT
WHAT THEY SEE.
MAKE YOUR SHERMAN NEVER STONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER.
CERTAINLY THERE ARE WE HAVE A
MOTION -- I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE
AMOUNT OF EXPENSE THAT A COUNTY
HAS TO GO THROUGH BOTH TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE PERSON
COURT IN THE COUNTY JAIL HAS THE
MEANS EVEN TO COVER THE COST.
AND SO FIRST YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT WHOLE PROCESS AND
THEN EVEN TRYING TO COLLECT --
THIS SEEMS TO ME -- A A BARRIER
THAT IS DOES NOT HAVE AS THE
AUTHOR PORTRAYED.
EIGHT ILLEGITIMATE LOGIC -- AND
IF WE LOOK AT WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT IN THIS I KNOW THAT THE
PURPOSE IS NOT TO MINIMIZE COSTS
BUT IF WE CONSIDER THE CONCERNS
MY COLLEAGUE.
REFERENED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ECONOMIC
STATUS OF THE VAST MAJORITY OF
OUR IF THE FOLKS WHO SERVE IN
OUR COUNTY JAILS.
THERE ARE FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS THEY HAVE THEY DID
NOT COME INTO JAIL AS BY AND
LARGE AS EITHER MIDDLE CLASS OR
WEALTHY PEOPLE.
SO.
THAT JUST BY CORRELATION THEY
PROBABLY DID NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
HEALTHCARE EVEN PRIOR TO GETTING
INTO COUNTY JAIL SO JUST GIVEN
OUR HEALTH SYSTEM WITHOUT
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE.
SO THEY ALREADY PROBABLY HAD
BUILT UP HEALTH AND MEDICAL
NEEDS -- IT'S JUST ANOTHER
FEATURE OF ARE UNFORTUNATE --
SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOWER INCOME HAVE MUCH LESS
ACCESS TO MANY -- SERVICES SO I
THINK YOUR BILL MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE -- WE HAVE A MOTION YOU
CAN CLOSE ON OUR CALL THE ROLL.
I JUST ASK YOUR ITEM THANK YOU.
ROLL CALL.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MORLOCK.
MORE LIKE I BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
MORALE.
AROUND NOW WINNER WIENER AYE.
I WILL HOLD THE BILL ON CALL
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME ABSENT
MEMBERS -- BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER HUMAN
[inaudible]
IN.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL SO I AM
GOING TO PASSED THE GAVEL. TO MY
VICE CHAIR.
THEY HAVE TO PRESENT AT ANOTHER
COMMITTEE -- BUT WE WILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR AB NINE SIXTY FIVE IS
A BILL THAT.
BRINGS TOGETHER THE THE WAY THAT
PRISONERS CAN.
OBTAIN CREDITS.
BOTH UNDER PROP FIFTY SEVEN AND
THEN YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE
CREDITS.
THE BENEFIT OF THE CREDIT SYSTEM
IS IT'S A WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE INSIDE ARE.
TAKING THE COURSE IS DOING THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT THEY NEED.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING ISSUES THAT LED THEM
INTO PRISON IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND WE KNOW WHEN THESE PROGRAMS
WORK.
THEY CAN THEIR SERIOUS FACTORS
IN REDUCING RECIDIVISM
THROUGHOUT THE POPULATION.
THE CHALLENGES AND THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHERE PROPERTY SEVEN WAS
SET UP.
WAS TO GIVE PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE COURSES TO
DO THINGS AND THEN THEY WOULD
HAVE.
AT OPPORTUNITY FOR EARLIER
PAROLE DATE.
MS WE HAVE A SEPARATE SECOND
SYSTEM THE YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE
SYSTEM.
AND THE WAY THAT PROP FIFTY
SEVEN CREDITS WORK IS IT IS ON
THE ORIGINAL SENTENCE FOR
SOMEBODY WHO IS A YOUTH IN THE
YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE PROGRAM.
AND SO IF IF THOSE CREDITS ARE
BEING TAKEN OFF THE ORIGINAL
SENTENCE NOT THE SENTENCE THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY SERVING BECAUSE
OF THE YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE
SYSTEM.
THOSE INCENTIVES GO AWAY.
WE KNOW THAT THE FOLKS WHO DO
THESE KINDS OF POGRAMS.
ARE SET MORE SUCCESSFUL WHEN
THEY GET OUT OF THE PUT INTO THE
PUBLIC THAT THEY DON'T RE OFFEND
AND IN FACT WITH RECIDIVISM
RATES RUNNING.
INTO THE 5060% IN CALIFORNIA.
THE YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE WITH
THOSE WHO GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS AND ARE PAROLED.
THE THE RECIDIVISM RATES ARE ONE
POINT SEVENTY TWO POINT 5%
DEPENDING ON THE YEAR THEY'RE
VERY SMALL SO IT'S A PROGRAM-THAT WORKS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE GIVEN UNDER THIS
STRUCTURE WITH PROP FIFTY SEVEN
AND YOU FEDERAL.
THAT WE'RE ALIGNING THE CREDIT
SYSTEM TO MAKE SOME SENSE MAKE
SURE THAT WORKS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PRESERVING THOSE
EFFICIENCIES AND THOSE
INCENTIVES FOR THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE INSIDE.
THAT'S THE POINT OF THIS BILL NO
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOUT.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TYAN OF ARGUS ADMIN I'M
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF INITIATE JUSTICE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
ACTIVATE THE POLITICAL POWER OF
THOSE IMPACTED BY MASS
INCARCERATION.
WE'RE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
NINE SIXTY FIVE FOR THREE KEY
REASONS WHY IN CALIFORNIA
SENTENCING LAWS ARE EXTREMELY
HARSH AND REMOVE HOPE FROM
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
EVEN WITH RELIEF UNDER USE
OFFENDER PAROLE TWENTY FIVE
YEARSIS A LONG TIME.
THIS SENSE OF HOPELESSNESS MAKES
PEOPLE MORE LIKELY TO MAKE THE
HARMFUL CHOICES THAT THREATEN
THE SAFETY OF THE INSTITUTION
AND PERPETUATES CYCLES OF
VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA. TWO THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT RELEASE IT'S
ONLY ABOUT ICENTIVIZING
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE ALL
CREDIT MUST BE EARNED THROUGH
THE COMPLETION EDUCATIONAL
REHABILITATIVE AND SELF HELP
PROGRAMS.
MOST PEOPLE WILL ACTUALLY NOT BE
RELEASED AT CDC ARE ONLY FINDS
AN AVERAGE OF 18% OF PEOPLE
SUITABLE FOR PAROLE EVERY YEAR.
AND ONLY 2% OF PEOPLE ARE FOUND
ELIGIBLE DURING THE FIRST PAROLE
HEARING WHICH THIS THESE WOULD
BE. THREE PEOPLE RELEASE UNDER
USE OFFENDER PAROLE HAVE THE
LOWEST RECIDIVISM RATE OF ANY
GROUP.
ACCORDING TO CDC ARE FOR FOLKS
REALLY CENTER YOU THE FENDER PRO
IN -- TWENTY FOURTEEN THEY HAD A
RECIDIVISM RATE OF 0% AFTER ONE
YEAR 0% AFTER TWO YEARS AND TWO
POINT 2% AFTER THREE YEARS.
THE OVERALL RECIDIVISM RATE FOR
THAT SAME YEAR WAS FORTY SIX
POINT 1%.
SENATORS AB NINE SIXTY FIVE WILL
PRESENT HOPE AN INCENTIVE FOR
PEOPLE TO INVEST THE TIME AND
WORK NECESSARY TO BE SUCCESSFUL
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
IT WILL HELP REDUCE OUR PRISON
POPULATION AND REUNITE FAMILIES
WHILE IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY
AND THE SAFETY OF THE
INSTITUTION AND THE COMMUNITY
OVERALL.
THE PROP FIFTY SEVEN REGULATION
SHOULD HAVE INCLUDED PEOPLE
ELIGIBLE FOR YOUTH OFFENDER
PAROLE.
THIS BILL WOULD CORRECT THAT AND
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
BEGIN TO END OUR ADDICTION TO
PUNISHMENT AND FOCUS ON
SOLUTIONS THAT ACTUALLY MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
THE MORNING CHAIR AND SENATORS.
MY NAME IS RICHARD MORALIS AND
I'M A MEMBER OF INITIATE JUSTICE
THIS IS NOW MY SECOND
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVOCATE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON GATES.
SINCE BEING RELEASED JUST NINETY
FIVE DAYS AGO.
I WAS SENTENCED TO TWENTY FIVE
YEARS TO LIFE AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY I WAS IN PRISON FOR
TWENTY YEARS SEVEN MONTHS AND
TWENTY ONE DAYS.
WHEN I FIRST WENT IN I COULDN'T
FATHOM THE OPPORTUNITY?
OF BEING FREE ONE DAY BUT HERE I
AM AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
AFTER NEARLY A YEAR IN I KNEW
THAT I NEEDED TO CHANGE.
I DON'T WANT TO DIS A DRUG
ADDICT IMPRISONED.
AT THE END OF NINETEEN NINETY
NINE WITH THE HELP OF GOD AND
FAMILY -- BARKED A NEW PATH.
I STARTED CARRYING A STARTED
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT I
DID AND FOR WHAT I COST AND FOR
MY LIFE IN THE FUTURE.
I HEAVILY PARTICIPATED IN SELF
HELP REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
AND EARNED A BACHELOR'S OF
SCIENCE DEGREE.
IN HEALTHCARE ADMINISTRATION
BECAME ONE OF SEVEN TO RECEIVE
SENATORIAL RECOGNITION -- FOR
BECOMING A STATE CERTIFIED
ALCOHOL AND DRUG COUNSELOR FROM
THE SENATOR THEN DARRELL
STEINBERG.
NOW THE MAYOR -- THAT PROGRAM IS
SPONSORED BY THE CROP
ORGANIZATION WHO NOW EMPLOYS ME
TODAY PROP FIFTY SEVEN ALLOW FOR
ME TO GET TO MY PAROLE BOARD
HEARING. NINE MONTHS EARLY BUT I
WAS NOT ALLOWED TO EARN ANY TIME
OFF OF MY YOU DEFENDER DAY.
SENATE BILLS TWO SIXTY TWO SIXTY
ONE A. B. THIRTEEN AWAIT AND
PROFIT D. SEVEN CREATED HOPE FOR
MANY OF MINE CAR SERRATED
FRIENDS WHO COULD NOT SEE.
A LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
BUT THERE ARE TOO MANY PEOPLE
STILL INSIDE WHO ARE WORKING
EXTREMELY HARD TO BETTER
THEMSELVES WITH NO INCENTIVE OR
NO HOPE OF EVER COMING HOME IN
THE FUTURE.
MY BEST FRIEND TED GRAY WHO CO
FOUNDED THE ORGANIZATION THE
CROP ORGANIZATION THAT I WORK
FOR TODAY.
HAS BEEN INCARCERATED FOR OVER
NINETEEN YEARS AND IS THE
HARDEST WORKING MAN I KNOW.
HE JUST COMPLETED HIS MASTER'S
DEGREE IN ORGANIZATIONAL
LEADERSHIP.
AND LEADS AND PARTICIPATES IN
MANY.
SELF HELP REHABILITATE OF GROUPS
I COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT HIM
AND OTHERS LIKE HIM WHO HAVE
WORKED HARD TO TRANSFORM THE
CULTURE PRISON.
THROUGH THOUGHT PRO SOCIAL
ACTIVITY BEHAVIOR AND ACTIONS.
WELL BECAUSE OF EXISTING LAW ALL
OF THE CREDITS THAT HE EARNS AND
OTHERS LIKE HIM -- WILL ONLY
COME OFF OF THEIR MAXIMUM OF
ENTER DATE INSTEAD OF THE YOUTH
OFFENDER DATE.
OF TWENTY FIVE YEARS IF AB NINE
SIXTY FIVE PASSES TED AND OTHERS
WHO HAVE WORKED VERY HARD COULD
GET TO THEIR PAROLE BOARD
HEARING A FEW YEARS SOONER.
AND HAVE A CHANCE TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
WHEN TESTIFYING BEFORE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AFTER MY TWELVE DAY OUT?
I REMEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER SAYING WE NEED TO TRUST
THAT OUR PAROLE BOARD
COMMISSIONERS.
ARE LAST BACKSTOP MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE WHO ALREADY ARE BEING
PAROLED.
AB NINE SIXTY FIVE WOULD NOT BE
A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD FOR
ANYONE.
IT IS SIMPLY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD
SOONER.
AND I CAN ATTEST TO THE FACT
THAT THE PAROLE BOARD IS A VERY
STRINGENT PROCESS I WAS IN THERE
FOR OVER SEVEN HOURS.
AND BELIEVE ME THEY LEFT NO
STONE UNTURNED.
HAD I BEEN DENIED THE MINIMUM
DENIAL I WOULD RECEIVE JUST
THREE YEARS.
I'M GRAY FORM FORTUNATE TO HAVE
EARNED TIME OFF MY SENTENCE BUT
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO KNOW THAT
I'M NOT AN ANOMALY.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUST WORK JUST AS HARD OR HARDER
THAN I HAVE.
BUT SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THE LWS ARE WRITTEN THEY HAVE
TO REMAIN IN PRISON WITH NO
OPPORTUNITY GO BEFORE THE PAROLE
BOARD.
YOU DEFENDER IS LIKE TEN WILL
EVENTUALLY GET OUT OF PRISON.
BUT I BELIEVE THE PUBLIC WOULD
PREFER IF THEY'RE RELEASED A FEW
YEARS EARLIER.
BECAUSE THEY WORK EXTRA HARD TO
EARN THEIR FREEDOM THROUGH THEIR
OWN REHABILITATION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE RIVAL FOR A.
B. NINE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU.
YOU MISTER MORALES GIVE.
IS SET CROP AN ACRONYM.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ERIC ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE A PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND ON BEHALF OF SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
JOSEPH CALDERON TRANSITIONS
CLINIC NETWORK WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
ROLL MARYLAND ROSTEN
REPRESENTING PROJECT REBOUND.
AND CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN PRISONERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BROWN'S WIFE FLIRT NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALL THE ROMERO WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION WEREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER CONTRAST NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
JANUARY TEARS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
MEN'S WORK ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF CALIFORNIANS TRANSFERRED.
GOOD MORNING DEREK MORGAN FOR
THE AKLAND BASED ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
MONEY ENSEMBLE DROUGHT OF THE
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
CONTRAST WITH YOU CAN WITH
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
AND SUPPORT.
FRANK WAS MINE WITH THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND AS A CO
AUTHOR IN PROPONENT OF PROPERTY
SEVEN AND YOU THE FENDER PRO
LAWS I SUPPORT BECAUSE THIS.
BILL -- IN FURTHERS THE INTENT
PURPOSE OF THOSE.
BOB.
THOSE TARA REHABILITATION AND
PUBLIC SAFETY FOCUS LAWS THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH THE
INTEREST OF THE COALITION
RADICAL SPONSORS SUPPORT.
AS SPAWNING AS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION PROD CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE BOY WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MIA NOR FROM ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE ASIAN LOCKER
CAUCUS AND ALSO AS A FORM THE
CURSOR COMMITTEE MEMBER I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
REFER CAPELLA NECK OF THE
BERKELEY NAACP.
AND ELLA BAKER CENTER.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALSO GIVE JUSTICE COALITION ARE
ONE OF THE FIRST SB TWO SIXTY
BENEFIT CHER'S STAR SUPPORT.
BOLIVIA'S SHIELDS OF THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU WANTED TO CLOSE IT WOULD
EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
PLEASE ISSUE ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
DYLAN THOMAS ELLA BAKER CENTER
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I WANT TO MAKE SOME ROOM AT THE
TABLE AND THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
pTHE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND WERE
IN OPPOSITION.
TO EIGHTY NINE SIXTY FIVE THE
CURRENT CREDIT ADOPTED BY CDC
ARE PURSUANT TO PROP FIFTY SEVEN
ALREADY APPLIED TO YOUTH
OFFENDERS.
ADDING CONDUCT CREDITS TO PC
THIRTY FIFTY ONE NOT ONLY GETS
VIOLENT OFFENDERS AND SEX
OFFENDERS RELEASED EVEN EARLIER.
IT EXACERBATES THE PROBLEM OF
TREATING MULTIPLE CRIME VICTIMS
THE SAME AS ONE CRIME.
SITE OFFENDERS WE SUPPORT
REHABILITATION BUT THERE NEEDS
TO BE PROPORTIONALITY BETWEEN
THE GRAVITY AND THE NUMBER OF
CRIMES.
AN INMATE MAKES AN ELIGIBILITY
FOR PAROLE AND FOR THESE REASONS
WHERE PROPOSED.
SHE TURNED MEMBERS CORSO'S ALONG
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION --
JUST POINT OUT THE EXISTING LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES THE POSSIBILITY
OF PAROLE DATE FOR OFFENDERS
WHETHER YOUTH YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS
WHETHERTHEY'RE DETERMINEDLY
SENDS.
IN A TERMINALLY SENSE OR SENSE
TO LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE LOG
GUARANTEES THAT THOSE PEOPLE.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME
BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD EVEN IN
THE CASE OF A DETERMINATE
SENTENCE.
THIS BILL -- FOR THOSE WHO ARE
INDETERMINATE LEE SENTENCED --
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO
BEFORE THE BOARD SOONER
UNDERSTANDING IT'S NOT A
GUARANTEE OF RELEASE -- BUT WE
FEEL THAT AGAIN AS THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S POINT OUT THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME PROPORTIONALITY
BETWEEN THE OFFENSE COMMITTED --
AND THE AND THE CONSEQUENCES FOR
THAT AND SO BECAUSE EXISTING LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GO BEFORE THE BOARD -- PRIOR
TO WIN YOUR SENSE WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN SURPLUS FOR NO
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SAUCIER Là ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR JEFF THANK YOU MY
UNDERSTANDING IS -- THE REASON
FOR THIS BILL CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG IS THAT.
UNDER THE CURRENT REGULATIONS
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS HAS
BEEN APPLYING.
OF THE CREDITS THE GOOD TIME
ANOTHER CREDITS NOT TOWARD THE
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER PAROLE DATE
WHICH IS THE EARLIER DATE.
BUT THE YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS
INITIAL PREPROGRAMMED DATE WHICH
MEANS THEY HAVEN'T ADJUSTED FOR
THE CHANGES.
IN THE LAW IN THE YOUTHFUL
OFFENDER.
PAROLE PROGRAMS SAID HE SAID
BASICALLY IT YES THAT'S THAT'S
IT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO AND SO.
YES UNDER THE YOUTHFUL OFFENDER
PROGRAM.
WHICH YOU COULD AGREE WITH OR
DISAGREE WITH THAT'S EXISTING
LAW THEY DO HAVE AN EARLIER DATE
FOR PAROLE.
BUT IF THEY'RE WORKING IN AND
WORKING ON CREDITS. TO IN THE
COURSE WORK DOING THE THINGS
THAT THEY NEED.
THOSE CREDITS APPLY TO THEIR
ORIGINAL SENTENCE NOT THE YOUTH
OFFENDER SENS SO THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY ABILITY TO GET TO A PAROLE
DATE EARLIER THAN THE YOUTH
OFFENDER PAROLE.
INITIALLY WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
BASED ON THE WORK THAT THEY DO
WHICH IS WHY.
THE INCENTIVES IN THIS CASE ARE
WORKING.
JACKSON I WAS SO EXCITED TO HEAR
YOUR QUESTION THAT I FAILED TO
ASK IF THERE WERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION YOU DID
AND I THOUGHT THAT -- SO WHEN I
HAVE MEANT THERE WEREN'T BUT
APPARENTLY THERE ARE ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT SIR CHAIR NUMBERS DON KEPT
HIM BEHALF OF CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
ANY ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ME FOR THE
INTERRUPTION I APOLOGIZE SO JUST
A COUPLE OF THE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE THE GOAL HERE IS.
TO WE'RE TRYING TO REHABILITATE
THESE YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS THAT'S
WHY WERE TRYING TO ADVANCE
CERTAIN PROGRAMS AND ARE SO WHAT
YOU'RE SUGGESTING IS THAT.
WITH OUT THIS LEGISLATION.
AND THE FACT THAT THESE YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS DON'T BENEFIT AT ALL --
OR BENEFIT VERY LITTLE WITH THE
WITH THESE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS THAT THIS CREATES AN
INCENTIVE THAT DOESN'T OTHERWISE
EXISTENCE THAT WRECKED.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES.
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE CLOSING COMMENTS I JUST
ASK FOR YOUR OF A THANK YOU --
GOOD MADAM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MUCH AS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORLOCK [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
JACKSON FIVE JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER AYE.
WE'LL GIVE THE VOTE THE BILL A
COUPLE WAS A VOTE PLEASE. ZERO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU ASSUME
OR STONE PROCEDURE BEING HERE.
SO REMEMBER GABRIEL WELCOME.
WELL NOW DO AB
.
ONE SIXTY FIVE YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
WHAT?
THANK YOU SIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY 2% AB ONE SIXTY
FIVE A BILL THAT WHEN SURE THAT
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
PROPERLY TRAINED ON THE USE OF
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
AS MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE EIJI
VERO IS A JUDICIAL ORDER THAT
ALLOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
TEMPORARILY REMOVE FIREARMS FROM
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO POSES AN
IMMINENT RISK OF HARM. TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS WHEN USED
TO THEIR FULL POTENTIAL G. V. R.
OWES ARE POWERFUL TOOL THAT CAN
PREVENT MASS SHOOTINGS AND
SUICIDES AND SAVE LIVES.
AND FORCING G. HEROES HAVE BEEN
UNDER UTILIZED SINCE THEY WERE
FIRST INTRODUCED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN UNLESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
ORDERS WERE ISSUED DURING THE
FIRST TWO YEARS THEY WERE
AVAILABLE.
THOSE NUMBERS INCREASE SOMEONE
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THANKS
LARGELY TO INNOVATIVE TRAINING
PIONEERED BY DISTRICT AND CITY
ATTORNEYS IN SEVERAL COUNTIES.
WHICH OF HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THOSE JURISDICTIONS BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHEN AND HOW TO SEEK
THESE ORDERS. FOR EXAMPLE A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE G. VARIOS
WERE ISSUED IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
LAST YEAR 43% OF THE STATEWIDE
TOTAL THANKS TO THE GOOD WORK OF
SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY MARI
ELLIOT.
WHO HAS BEEN A KEY ADVOCATE AND
LEADER FOR INCREASED TWO G. B.
R. O. TRAINING?
THE STATISTIC SHOWS THE TRAINING
WORKS AND THAT WE NEED STATEWIDE
TRAINING TO ENSURE THAT THIS
POWERFUL TOOL IS BEING USED TO
ITS FULL POTENTIAL SO THAT OUR
OFFICERS CAN KEEP THEMSELVES IN
THE PUBLIC SAFE.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND GUN VIOLENCE
ORGANIZATIONS HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE TWO
LEADING ADVOCATES STEVE LINLEY
FROM THE BRADY CAMPAIGN TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE AND JULIA
WEBER FROM THE DIFFERENCE
LAWCENTER.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
ONE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU.
MISTER LILLY OF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU SIR.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN PRETTY
CALIFORNIA WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE PASSAGE OF AB -- TEN
FOURTEEN WHICH ALLOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT FAMILIES AND
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS TO PETITION
THE COURT TO OBTAIN A GONNA BUY
FOR IN ORDER WHEN A PERSON IS AT
RISK OF INJURY. TO SELF OR
OTHERS.
HAVING A FINAL SUCH ORDERS TO
PRETTY PROHIBIT THE PURCHASE A
POSITION OF FIREARMS OR THE
ORDER IS IN EFFECT AND ALLOW
WARRANT TO BE ISSUED TO SEIZE
THESE FIREARMS AMMUNITION
MAGAZINES.
ALTHOUGH THE GT R. O. LAW.
HAS NOT BEEN AFFECT OVER THREE
YEARS IS EVIDENT THAT MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES EITHER DO
NOT KNOW ABOUT THE LAW.
DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN
FILL GAPS IN EXISTING LAW OR DO
NOT HAVE A PROCESS FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE LAW.
IN THEIR JURISDICTIONS.
WE SUPPORT ANY TRAINING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT I CAN FURTHER THE G.
V. R. O. PROGRAM WE'VE SEEN IN
OTHER STATES THAT IT IS
EFFECTIVE HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA
I THINK WE WE MISSED THE MARK
INITIALLY.
BY NOT PROVIDING ENOUGH TRAINING
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND WITH THIS BILL WE'RE HOPING
TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
IN INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF G.
ROSE TO MAKE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
A SAFER PLACE.
THANK YOU THIS WEBER.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JULIA WEBER I'M
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
GIFFORDS LAW CENTER TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT OF AND
AS A SPONSOR OF AB.
ONE SIXTY FIVE I'VE WORKED IN
THE FIELD OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION RESPONSE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS INCLUDING
DEVELOPING A RESTRAINING ORDER
POLICY WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
TRAINING JUDICIAL OFFICERS AND
STAFF TEACHING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
LOG GOLDEN GATE UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL OF LAW.
AND I'M CURRENTLY SERVING AS THE
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
IMPLEMENTATION FELLOW WITH THE
DIFFERENCE LAWCENTER.
ALL WHICH MEANS I'M DOING
STATEWIDE OUTREACH ON THE G. V.
R. O. AND TRAINING AND HAS ALL
ON THE HAS ALREADY BEEN POINTED
OUT -- WE KNOW THE G. V. R. O.
HAS BEEN UNDER UTILIZED AND I'M
SEEING THAT AS I GROW ACROSS THE
STATE AND TALK WITH COURTS.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ABOUT SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES -- WE BELIEVE
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL ARE I WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE G. V. R. O. IS
A CIVIL NOT A CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
PLAYS A HOWEVER A SIGNIFICANT
ROLE IN G. B. R. OWES.
AND IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
FROM OTHER RESTRAINING ORDER
PROCESS SEES.
THERE ARE PARTIES IN THESE
MATTERS THEIR PARTICIPATION
LEGAL PROCESS WITH THEIR
DECLARATIONS FILING THE CORRECT
FORMS APPEARING FOR TESTIMONY.
THAT'S ALL CRITICAL.
AND NONE OF THAT CAN HAPPEN
WITHOUT THE APPROPRIATE TRAINING --
IN ADDITION TO FILING THE FORMS
TESTIFYING APPEARING AT THE
HEARINGS THEY'RE ALSO EXPECTED
TO SERVE AND ENFORCE THESE
ORDERS.
WHICH INCLUDES REQUESTING THAT
THE RESTRAINT PARTY TURN OVER
THEIR FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION
WHEN THEY BECOME PROHIBITED.
AND OF COURSE THIS CAN BE A VERY
DANGEROUS TIME FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FOR OTHERS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT TRAINING TO
SUPPORT SAVE IN A AFFECTED
PROCEDURES IN THIS AREA IS
CRITICAL -- WE ALSO KNOW THAT
TRAINING CAN LEAD TO LOCAL
PROTOCOL DEVELOPMENT BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE COURTS.
AND MORE ROBUST IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS IMPORTANT LAW WHICH CAN
ULTIMATELY SAVE MORE LIVES.
AB ONE SIXTY FIVE WILL BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING THE WORD
OUT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INCREASING THEIR ACCESS TO THIS
CRITICAL TOOL.
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE I THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS EMILY ALL I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS AND HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CRYSTAL OF LOTTO AND LIVE IN
ALAMEDA I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
DONNA SITES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CARE ROSSUM BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF STOCKTON MAYOR
MICHAEL TUBBS ITS SUPPORT.
I HAVE A COMPARISON BEHALF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STERN
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT.
LAURIE WALL FALLING TEAR WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION I DROVE UP
FROM THE BAY AREA TODAY IN
SUPPORT.
HI AM CIRCLE ARE THE IN A LITTLE
TOO WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FROM
DANVILLE I SUPPORT.
HELLO IN THE AIDS MOMS DEMAND
ACTION DROVE IN FROM ORANGE
FAILED STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS AMY HOW CAN A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOE CROWLEY A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION I SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS CAROL ROGERS I DROVE
IN FROM ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA.
IN I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PERSONAL CLOSE HERE ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY MIKE
FAIR AND LOS ANGELES A CITY
MAYOR.
OR CITY IN SUPPORT.
MARY LOU ROSSETTO FORMER POLICE
OFFICER MULLIN TEAR WITH THAT
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION -- FROM
DAVIS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
CYNTHIA SHELL IT I'M A SUPPORTER
MEMBER OF MOM SPEND ACTION FOR
GUN SENSE IN AMERICA I JUST
WANTED TO RELATE A A LOCAL STORY --
I MET WITH US IS NOW CARROLLWOOD
SO ALONG WITH A BRIEF PROJECT
REPRESENTATIVE.
SHE'S THE CITY ATTORNEY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND AFTER THEY
RECEIVED -- HERE ACTUALLY NOT
TAKING TESTIMONY AFTER THE
PERCENT WITH THEY SHOULD GIVE
URALS WENT FROM ZERO TO EIGHT IN
THE LAST FEW MONTHS THANKS THANK
YOU.
A LISA ROAD TO PARMA I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND I'LL ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT BILL.
I AM KAREN'S AN AUTO I AM A
VOLUNTEER AT MONTHS MAN ACTION
FROM WEST SACRAMENTO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT FILL.
AND CASSANDRA WET STONE OF
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SO WE KEEPING A CAN VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR -- NINE FIVE EIGHT ONE
FOUR KEVIN MCCARTY IS DISTRICT --
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND ICE
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
pWOULD HIGH SCHOOL IN ROCKLIN AND
IN SUPPORT.
ADAM TAKEN ON BEHALF OF EVERY
TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD THING A POSITION --
RESIDENT SECOND COUNTY AND ALSO
ON HER FOR MONTHS MAN ACTION
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE.
THIS.
ONE SEEING NO WITNESSES TôI WE
HAVE A MOTION DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
WE'VE GOT TO MOTIONS DIRE.
THREE OF A MOVE IT [inaudible]
THERE'S THREE GENERAL YOU WANNA.
JOINT IN IT.
LIMON GABRIEL PLEASE -- YOUR
CLOSING STATEMENT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH JUST AS
I'LL JUST ADD THAT THE YOU KNOW
THE DATA SUGGESTS THAT THERE'S
ON THE UNDER UTILIZATION OF G.
R. I WAS BY.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF PERSONAL
ANECDOTES AS WELL JUST WANTED TO
RELAY ONE FROM AMANDA WILCOX USE
WITH THE BRADY CAMPAIGN WHO WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE HEARD -- RAN OVER
TO ANOTHER -- EVENT THAT SHE HAD
TO BE AT HER DAUGHTER -- PASSED
AWAY AS A RESULT OF GUN VIOLENCE
AND SHE SHARED THAT THE SOME OF
THE MOST SENIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN THE AREA WHERE SHE
LIVES WERE ON AWARE OF THE OF
THE G. VERO.
LAW AND THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
THEY HAD TO USE THIS TOOL IS
ONLY THROUGH A CONVERSATION THAT
SHE HAD WITH THEM.
THAT THEY BECAME AWARE OF THIS
VERY POWERFUL TOOL SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT
WE NEED TO INCREASE TRAINING FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSUME AND GABRIEL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS THE PAST TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORE LOCK ALL RIGHT WELL LIKE I
BRADFORD.
JACKSON FIVE JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WIENER RIGHT WIENER AYE.
THAT HAS FOUR VOTES.
AND WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN TILL
FIVE WE CONCLUDE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HELPING ME OUT
HERE.
THAT TAKES US TO ITEM. FIFTEEN
AB.
ONE ZERO ZERO NINE YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB. ONE
ZERO ZERO NINE A BILL TO
MODERNIZE THE STATE'S FIREARM
REGISTRATION PROCESS SAVE
TAXPAYER RESOURCES TO ENSURE LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS ACCESS TO
ACCURATE AND RELIABLE DATA.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CERTAIN FARM
TRANSACTIONS MUST BE REPORTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE EITHER
THROUGH MAILING OR ONLINE FORMS.
THIS INCLUDES SELF REPORTED FARM
OWNERSHIP REPORTS NEW RESIDENT
REPORTS INTERFERE MILLIA
TRANSFER REPORTS INTERIOR OR
RELIC FIREARM REPORTS.
THE GOP THE DOJ HAS FOUND IN IT
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF FIREARM
REGISTRATIONS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED VIA MAIL.
MAIL IN FORMS CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO READ ARE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
TO TAKE LONGER FOR THE DOJ TO
PROCESS.
IN RESPONSE THIS BILL ADJUST THE
FARM REGISTRATION PROCESS TO
ENCOURAGE ONLINE REGISTRATION
AND TO ALLOW THE DOJ TO PLACE A
REASONABLE SURCHARGE NOT TO
EXCEED TWENTY DOLLARS ON MAIL IN
REGISTRATION FORMS.
THIS REPRESENTS THE ADDITIONAL
COST OF RECEIVING AND PROCESSING
THE REPORT AND INJURES THE DOJ
HAS THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
PROCESS REGISTRATION FORMS IN A
TIMELY AND EFFICIENT FASHION.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
ACTUALLY AIRS DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THANK YOU AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
THEY ARE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OFFICE.
I ON BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT
WOULD LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL FOR OFFERING THIS
BILL.
AGAIN AS THE MEMBER EXPLAIN THIS
BILL CONTEMPLATE SIX FORMS THAT
ARE SUBMITTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
FIREARMS REPORTING SYSTEM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS C. FARR'S.
THOSE FORMS FIREARM OWNERSHIP
REPORT INTERVIEW MILLER FAMILY
REPORTS AS WELL AS CARRY ON
RELIC FORMS.
THE FORM CAN CURRENTLY BE
SUBMITTED ONLINE OR VIA MAIL THE
IDEA IT AND POINT PURPOSE OF THE
BILL IS TO IT I HAVE ATTACH
ADDITIONAL TWENTY DOLLAR FEE.
FOR THE FORM THAT ARE GOING TO
BE SUBMITTED BY BY MAIL TO
REFLECT THE ADDITIONAL COST OF
THOSE FORMS IN THE PROCESSING
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE RECEIVED APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND FORM SUBMITTED
ONLINE LAST YOU HEARD IN TOTAL
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND FORMS LAST
YEAR.
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
OF THEM WERE BY MAILAND
APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND OF%
THEM WERE SUBMITTED ONLINE THE
IDEA IS TO ENCOURAGE ONLINE
PROCESSING WHICH IS QUICKER
EASIER AND MORE EFFICIENT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT.
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PERSONAL CLOSE HERE ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT. FIFTEEN
HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
STEVE ONLY WITH THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT.
I HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
MOTION THAT I KNOW --
ASSEMBLYMAN GABRIEL YOUR CLOSING
REMARKS CREATIONS.
SKINNER MORLOCK I MOORLACH AYE
BRADFORD JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
AROUND NOW WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
IT'S FOUR ONE AND WE WILL HOLD
THAT I TO PUT AN ITEM OPEN AS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
RIGHT
.
I'D LIKE TO THE CALENDAR.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE.
SKINNER MORE LOCK ON ME LIKE I
BRADFORD JACKSON LIKE JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND.
MORRELL AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
PASSES FIVE ZERO WILL HOLD THAT
OPEN AS WELL [inaudible]
YEAH.
REMAIN FIELD REPORTS ON THESE
IN MY DIARY I WAS THE ONLY.
ONE WELL NUMBER [inaudible]
ONE I'M AROUND [inaudible] ONE
FIVE ITEM FOURTEEN ITEM --
FOURTEEN AB [inaudible]
NINE SIXTY FIVE I AM.
YEAH MOTION ALWAYS IT'S OF
MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MOORLACH [inaudible]
BRADFORD MORALE.
NO.
AROUND THEM.
OKAY I WAS THE HOLD UP ONE OPEN.
GREAT.
THE THING ELSE SENATOR MITCHELL.
BUT I THAT.
I LIKE THE IDEA [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SO -- SERGEANT IF YOU COULD --
ASK BECAUSE SOME OF OUR MEMBERS.
MUST BE BUSY MORNING.
COMMENTED ON SOMETHING.
I THINK THEY'RE DOING.
THE TRAINING WHEELS A THREE AT
ONE YEAH.
PERHAPS ALL.
RIGHT YEAH
GRAYSON YOU YOU HAVE
AT YOUR WHERE WE'VE BEEN WAITING.
FOR IN THIS WOULD BE ITEM
SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE ONE ONE SEVEN WE HONOR TO
HAVE YOU HERE.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND SOON AS
YOU'RE READY WE'LL START.
THANK YOU.
SENATE SENATOR MITCHELL'S BEEN
HELPING US BE MORE EFFICIENT
ESOS [inaudible]
WONDERFUL [inaudible]
YOU READY.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU WERE
READY.
SENATE RACE FOR SENATOR GRAYSON
ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON.
YOUR FLOOR.
THANK YOU BYE STERN AND THE
SENATORS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT --
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
WHICH WILL CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS FOR
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN TRAINED PEER SUPPORT
TEAM MEMBERSAND THEIR FELLOW
PEACE OFFICERS.
THE PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM IS TO
ENCOURAGE PEACE OFFICERS TO SEEK
TREATMENT AND SUPPORT FOR
DRAMATIC STRESS BEFORE IT
MANIFESTS INTO MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS.
IN A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STUDY ROUGHLY
75% OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
REPORTED EXPERIENCING A
TRAUMATIC EVENT.
BUT LESS THAN HALF OF THEM TOLD
THEIR AGENCY ABOUT IT.
EVEN MORE TROUBLING ABOUT HALF
OF THE OFFICERS REPORTED
PERSONALLY KNOWING ANOTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WHO CHANGED
AFTER EXPERIENCING A TRAUMATIC
EVENT.
BUT ONLY ABOUT HALF REPORTED
KNOWING AN OFFICER THE END IN
ADDITION THAT HALF REPORTED
KNOWING AN OFFICER WHO HAD
COMMITTED SUICIDE.
PEACE OFFICERS ARE OFTEN
RELUCTANT TO UTILIZE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES BECAUSE OF THE
FEAR OF ADVERSE JOB IMPACTS THE
STIGMA SURROUNDING MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
AND THE PERCEPTION AMONG LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY MUST SHOW
NO SIGNS OF WEAKNESS.
THE ABILITY TO SPEAK WITH A PEER
SUPPORT OR WITH HERE.
WHO HAS SHARED EXPERIENCE AND
SHARED UNDERSTANDING IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
POPULATIONS THAT ARE TYPICALLY
RELUCTANT TO SPEAK WITHOUT
SIDERS?
IN OTHER SETTINGS YOUR SUPPORT
HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE
IN HELPING PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE
WITH ADDICTION AND ALSO IT'S
BEEN USED TO HELP FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WITH
THEIR RE ENTRY INTO SOCIETY.
THIS BILL IS FIRST AND FOREMOST
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO ALLOW OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN UNIFORM TO SUFFER
IN SILENCE.
BY PROVIDING FOR CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION WITH TRAINED PEER
SUPPORT PERSONNEL AB ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN WILL ENCOURAGE PEACE
OFFICERS TO SEEK THE SUPPORT AND
TREATMENT THEY NEED IN TIME TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
MY WITNESSES TODAY -- WAS SELF
INTRODUCE AND WITH THE
PERMISSION OF OYSTER
[inaudible]
PLEASE WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SEVEN WALKER I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR CCPOA I
AM ALSO A YOUTH CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER -- OUR MODEL IS OUTDATED
IT'S THAT SIMPLE -- YOU WE'RE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A SYSTEM
THAT WAS.
BUILT IN THE FORTIES -- AND THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE PRE DATE THAT --
THE THING WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
IS THAT WE CAN NOT CONTINUE TO
DENY THE OBVIOUS.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM OUR SYSTEM IS
BROKEN.
AND IT'S IN CAPABLE OR AN
INTERESTED IN RESOLVING THE
PROBLEM.
WE'RE ASKING MOSTLY YOUNG MEN
AND WOMEN. TO SEE AN ENGAGE WITH
HUMANITY IN EVERY CONCEIVABLE
MANIFESTATION OF THE HUMAN
SPIRIT SOLD IN MIND ALL THE
WHILE WE ARE DEMANDING THEY
SWIPE THEIR HUMANITY OFTEN ON
THE SCREEN AS IF IT WERE A NAP.
THE PUBLIC DEMAND IS FOR
OFFICERS TO HAVE THE RIGHT
ANSWER AND TO BE HELPFUL IN
THEIR TIME OF NEED.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE SPENT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN HOURS ARE
SPENT.
ON UNDERSTANDING WHAT A BULLET
OR A CELL DOES TO HUMANITY.
BUT THE COST IS TOO HIGH TO
INVEST IN THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
SOUL OF AN OFFICER.
SILENCE IS BROKEN BY SILENCE OUR
OUR BY SUICIDE.
WE CANNOT RESORT TO SPIN OUR
AGENCIES ARE CONTINUING. TO TO
LIE TO THE PUBLIC AND SAY THAT
THE ACTIONS OF ONE BAD OFFICER
DOESN'T TAINT THE WORK OF ALL
THE DEDICATED MEN AND WOMEN ON
THE LINE.
YES IT DOES.
TRAINING TECHNOLOGY IN
TERMINATION OF THE SOLUTION TO
EVERY TO EVERYPROBLEMS FOR THE
AGENCY.
IT IT ISN'T.
WE GIVE OUR OFFICES THE TOOLS
DATE THEY CONTEND THAT WE GIVE
OUR OFFICES DIDN'T.
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO DO THE
JOB.
AND IT'S THEIR JOB TO DEAL WITH
THE NEEDS STATE OF THE DEVELOP
AS A RESULT OF THE TO OF THE JOB.
BOTTOM LINE IF WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE THIS SYSTEM.
IF WE IF WE WANT THIS SYSTEM TO
CHANGE WE HAVE TO BEGIN WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE THE FOUNDATION
OF IT -- WE CAN EITHER INVEST.
IN DISCIPLINE.
ARE WE CAN INVEST IN HELPING
PEOPLE.
IS THAT SIMPLE A WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE A SYSTEM OF
HELP.
OF REHABILITATION OF RESTORATION.
BUT NOT FOR THE PEOPLE EMPLOYED
IN IT.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THESE WITH.
JUST ONE WITNESS OKAY.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER WALKER YOU
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
BENEFIT TRUST FUND IN SUPPORT.
FUTURE MEMBERSHIP LEVINE ON
BEHALF OF COLONEL RIPLEY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHEN MISTER RYAN SHERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
AND ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES.
YOUR LIGHT ON SINCE I DO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU FIND.
I JUST WANNA A KNOWLEDGE -- ON
THE COMMENTS MADE ON BY THE
WITNESS AND SUPPORT I WAS STRUCK.
ON BY YOUR REPEATED USE OF THE
TERM HUMANITY.
AND HOW -- REAL THAT AS AND HOW
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT IT IS AN
ISSUE OF HUMANITY FOR FOR BOTH
THOSE WHO WORK IN THE SYSTEM.
AND THOSE WHO -- ARE
INCARCERATED IN THE SYSTEM SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD IN YOUR
COMMENTS AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE CLOSING COMMENTS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
GRAYSON I WOULD THANK YOU -- I
AM.
STILL CURRENTLY OF CRITICAL
RESPONSE CHAPLAIN FOR A LOCAL
AGENCY.
AND I SEE DAILY THE THE NEED.
THAT PRESSES HAS TO HELP OUR
OFFICERS OF THOSE IN UNIFORM.
FIRST RESPONDERS AS WELL AS
THOSE THAT ARE BEING
REINTRODUCED BACK INTO OUR
SOCIETY THAT HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SUPPORT THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
DEALS.
WITH OUR PEACE OFFICERS -- AND
THE FACT THAT -- HUMANITY IS A
HUGE PART OF THEM THEY DON'T
LOSE THAT HUMANITY BY SERVING US
AS FIRST RESPONDERS.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
INVEST IN THEM.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED SO THAT IT
DOESN'T END UP A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS SO WITH THAT SENATORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MOORLACH I WILL LIKE I BRADFORD
JACKSON MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
THAT HAS THREE VOTES -- WILL
HOLD.
THAT.
ARE ON CALL AND RISK THANK YOU
FOR COMING THANK YOU.
WE HAVE. TO MEMORIZE MOST
BELIEVE WOULD BE NEXT.
WITH THE ITEM H. A. B.
[inaudible]
FOUR THREE THREE WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF SURVEYS
CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU I'M SENATORS.
AB FOR THREE THREE REQUIRES
CRIME VICTIMS FOR PROSECUTING
ATTORNEYS TO BE MADE AWARE OF
EARLY TERMINATION OF PROBATION.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT TO NOTIFY CRIME
VICTIMS.
WHEN A PROBATION TERMS
TERMINATED EARLY BY THE COURT'S
ORDER?
THIS CAN LEAD TO SITUATIONS
WHERE VICTIMS ARE UNAWARE OF THE
TERMINATION OF PROBATION IN
THEIR CASES.
IN CASES WHERE RESTITUTION ORDER
HAS BEEN GRANTED BY A JUDGE AND
THERE IS AN EARLY TERMINATION OF
PROBATION.
IF THIS ORDER IS NOT FINALIZED
THE VICTIM CAN BE SETTLED WITH
THE MEN'S FINANCIAL COST ALONG
SIDE THE BURDEN OF VICTIMIZATION.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A TWO DAY
NOTIFICATION TO THE VICTIM OF
CRIME.
OF AN EARLY TERMINATION OF
PROBATION IN CASES WHERE
RESTITUTION HAS ALREADY BEEN
GRANTED BY A JUDGE.
THIS GIVES VICTIMS OF VOICE AND
GUARANTEES A RESTITUTION ORDERS
ARE FINALIZED PROMPTLY.
AB FOR THREE THREE INSURERS THAT
VICTIMS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEEK TO RESTITUTION PROMISED TO
THEM THROUGH THE JUDICIAL
PROCESS.
AND ENTITLED TO THEM UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONSTITUTION.
THIS BILL IS A COMMONSENSE
ADJUSTMENT TO EXISTING LAW TO
ENSURE WE DO RIGHT BY THE
VICTIMS OF CRIME.
WITH ME TODAY IS DON KEPT KEY
REPRESENTING CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
TO GIVE TESTIMONY.
THANKS TO VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR RURAL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMAN.
RAMOS RISK UPKEEP THANK YEAR --
DON CAP KEY MCCUE CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED OF CALIFORNIA I'M
PLEASED TO BE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL -- FOUR THIRTY
THREE AS A SOME WOMEN RAMOS
MENTIONED ON THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE A VIA THE PROSECUTING
ATTORNEYS -- TWO DAYS
NOTIFICATION TO VICTIMS WELL
WHERE A VICTIM HAS REQUESTED TO
BE NOTIFIED OF THE DISPOSITION
OF ON THEIR CASE -- AND ALLOW
YOU TO BE A THAT NOTIFICATION
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY IN.
CASES WHERE A VICTIM -- WHILE
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN GRANTED.
RESTITUTION OF BY THE COURTS AT
THE TIME OF SENTENCING ARE THERE
ARE SOME OCCASIONS THAT ARISE
WHERE THE FULL AND COSTS OF I
THEIR LOSSES WHETHER BE RELATED.
TO HEALTH CARE COSTS MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELING WHAT HAVE YOU
A RELOCATION EXPENSES MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE FULLY.
UNDERSTOOD AND QUANTIFIED AT THE
TIME OF SENTENCING Là NOT
ORIGINAL RESTITUTION ORDER WAS --
PROVIDED SAID THIS BILL WOULD
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY I TO
PROVIDE THAT NOTICE TO VICTIMS
WHO WOULD NOT OTHERWISE NO THE
PROBATION -- MAY BE TERMINATED
AND BY THAT TERMINATION WOULD
LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
THEIR CASE TO THE COURTS TO THAT.
PERHAPS ADDITIONAL RESTITUTION
MAY BE WARRANTED I SAW VIA THIS
TWO DAY NOTIFICATION WOULD
PROVIDE THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
VICTIM TO BE AWARE OF THAT.
I TO REQUEST THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO HAVE THE COURTS RECONSIDER
ADDITIONAL RESTITUTION WHO PUT
CERTAINLY YOU IN A RETAIN THE
ONUS ON THE VICTIM TO MAKE THE
CASE.
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL RESTITUTION
THAT MAY BE WARRANTED -- BUT
THAT NOTIFICATION IS CRITICAL TO
EVEN HAVING THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SO SO WITHOUT A CONVICT AND
UNITED IS PLEASED BY SUPPORT AB
FOR THIRTY THREE ENDEAVOR CHRIS
BUCKLEY CREST DRIVE OUT THANK
YOU.
Q. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTINE WARD WITH
CRIME VICTIMS ACTION ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SEEING NINE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
STATEMENT THIS SERMON RAMOS
THANK AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORE LAX ALL RIGHT MOORLACH AYE
BRADFORD JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WELL I WIENER.
THAT HAS SAID THREE ZERO IS ON
CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
WE TAKE BILLS AND AND YOU.
KNOW.
NUMERICAL ORDER -- SO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS REYES GIPSON
HAVE BEEN HERE ON EARLY BUT I
THINK IT'S A SERMON CUNNINGHAM
WOULD BE TECHNICALLY NEXUS HE'S
STILL IN THE ROOM.
ALL RIGHT BONUS THAT AT THAT
TAKES THE STAND -- TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON IF I COULD.
THIS SHOULD BE FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER.
TWELVE WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS
FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHT AT SEVEN I WHICH SEEKS TO
CLOSE THE GUN A LOOPHOLE LAW
THAT EXISTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
LET ME JUST POINT OUT A FEW
POINTS THIS BILL REQUIRES A
STATE BACK STATE BACKGROUND
CHECK FOR PURCHASERS UP ON
FINISH FRAMES AND RECEIVERS AND
REQUIRES.
THAT ALL PURCHASERS TAKE PLACE
THROUGH A LICENSED GUN DEALER
UNDERSCORE LICENSE -- GUN IT
DEALER CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR BOTH GUN
SALES AND AMMUNITION YET TO
SILENCE ON THE TREATMENT OF FIRE
ARMS PARTS.
THIS BILL INTENDS TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY BY PREVENTING
CRIMINALS AND THOSE WHO COULD
NOT OTHERWISE POSSESS FAR ARMS
FROM GAINING ACCESS WHILE
KEEPING THE RIGHTS OF GUN OWNERS.
IN TAX AND I'VE MENTIONED IN.
TWO TO BE MORE SPECIFIC THIS
BILL WOULD HAVE PREVENTED.
ABLE RAMOS FROM ASSEMBLING A
GHOST GUN THAT HE USED TO KILL.
TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD OFFICER
O'SULLIVAN HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
JUST ONE WEEK AGO RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
MAY INTERRUPT YOU FOR JUST A
SECOND -- I JUST WONDER SURE
THAT.
AUDIENCE TO MY COLLEAGUES THAT
THE GENTLEMAN -- PUTTING.
ALL VARIOUS PARTS ON THE TABLE --
IS HERE WITH APPROVAL FROM THE
SERGEANT.
AT THE ONES WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
AND I ESCORTED HIM INTO THE
BUILDING THIS MORNING SO WE
SHOULD BE FINE.
THE OTHER BRIDGE CALM DOWN.
INCLUDING SENATOR MITCHELL.
THE MEMBER GIPSON THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME JUST MAKE THAT
CLARIFICATION NOT A PROBLEM
CENTER THANK YOU FOR ESCORTING
THEM IN THE PRE SHAPE.
OF THAT ABLE RAMOS HAS A LONG --
CRIMINAL HISTORY WITH THE
CHARGES DATING BACK TO THE MID
NINETEEN NINETIES THE MOST
RECENT CRIMINAL CASE WAS FILED
IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AGAINST A YOUNG WOMAN.
ABLE RAMOS WAS PROHIBITED A
PROHIBIT PERSON WHO COULD NOT
LEGALLY PURCHASE A FAR ARM.
AND THAT IS WHY HE TURNED TO
MAKING.
HIS OWN GUN BY USING ASSISTANCE
FROM OF THE INTERNET.
IF THIS BILL HAD BEEN IT.
HAD BEEN PASSED LAST YEAR --
MISTER RAMOS WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ASSEMBLE -- THIS GOES
GUN AND POTENTIALLY.
OFFICER O'SULLIVAN WOULD BE
ALIVE TODAY.
YESTERDAY WE ADJOURNED IN HER
MEMORY ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
TODAY.
LEGISLATORS WE WILL REMEMBER HER
WORK.
OF BY PROVIDING PUBLIC SAFETY --
TO SACRAMENTO IAN'S -- AS SHE
DID HER DUTY AS A POLICE OFFICER
HERE IN SACRAMENTO -- WE SENT
OUT HER OUR PRAYERS. TO HER
FAMILY AND FRIENDS ALL THAT KNEW
HER -- END OF WATCH WE SAY THAT
AS I AM A FORMER POLICE OFFICER
WE STAY IN OF WATCH WHEN AN
OFFICER HAS LOST THEIR LIFE --
IN DUTY.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE -- TO
TURNED OVER TO A REPRESENTATIVE
DEPORT REPRESENTING THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE WHO GIVE
FURTHER CLARIFICATION SUPPORT OF
A. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE GOOD MORNING --
BILLY GRAHAM OF SPECIAL AGENT IN
CHARGE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE BUREAU FIREARMS -- I'M
HERE FOR TEXTILE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE IN CASE OR QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE WEAPONS WERE ITEMS
DESCRIBED IN THE BILL -- HAVE
SOME SAMPLES HERE AND COUPLE
THINGS I WANT TO POINT OUT IN
THIS BILL -- THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE WOULD BE REQUIRED.
TO CREATE A A PRODUCT IN IF YOU
WILL THAT WOULD HAVE PICKED
TWIRLS AND DIAGRAMS ETCETERA. TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THESE ITEMS ARE
AND PEOPLE COULD SIXTEEN FIVE
THREE ONE WHICH IS WHAT
DESCRIBES WHAT A PRECURSOR PART
IS AND FINISH RECEIVERS.
THAT ARE THE THE MAIN FOCUS OF
THE BILL -- AND THEN SECONDLY --
ANY PRECURSOR PARKS IDENTIFIED
IN THIS SECTION -- THEY ARE IN A
SINCERE EXEMPTED FROM THIS BILL
IF THEY ARE SOLD IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE FIRE.
SO -- THAT I JUST WANT TO POINT
THAT OUT SO THERE'S AN EXEMPTION
BASICALLY FOR JUST POINT PARKS
TO BUILD THEY WOULD HAVE TO HAVE
THIS -- BACKGROUND CHECK BEFORE
BUYING A FULL WORKING WEAPON
THERE'S NO SECONDARY CHECKS OR
ANYTHING WOULD REALLY HAPPEN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS EMILY ALL I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ENGINE THANK A VOLUNTEER FOR
MONSTER AND ACTION SPORTS BILL.
MY NAME'S CRYSTAL OF WATER FROM
ALAMEDA I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION CARES FOR
THIS BILL.
CALVET QUICKLY AREAS STERN
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT.
DONNA SITE YOU'RE VISITING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
LAURIE WALL FALL INTO WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FROM DANVILLE IN
SUPPORT.
HI AM CIRCLE ARE FROM DANVILLE
MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND SUPPORT.
ELIMINATES ORANGE FAIL MOMS
DEMAND ACTION SUPPORT.
HI ANGELA CROWLEY WITH VOLATILE
MONSTER MAN ACTION I SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS AMY HOW THEM ALONG TO
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STEVE ONLY WITH THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARY LOU RISOTTO -- FEEL COUNTY
MOMS DEMAND ACTION I SUPPORT.
CAL ROGERS VOLUNTEER WITH
CAPITAL AREA MOMS DEMAND ACTION
FROM ELK GROVE.
I SUPPORT. TO BE A SHALLOW THE
SPORT OF MOMS DEMAND ACTION
CONSENSUS AMERICA SACRAMENTO I
SUPPORT THANKS.
LISA RITUPARNA VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION I'M FROM
WALNUT GROVE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
KAREN'S AN AUTO VOLUNTEER
HUNTSMAN ACTION FROM WEST
SACRAMENTO AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CASSANDRA WHAT STONE A VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I HAVE THIRTY KEEPING GUNS
SURVIVOR -- MONSTER INACTION
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO AND ALSO AS
A STUDENTS ARE GOING TO CITIES
LIBER TECHNICIAN PROGRAM WE WORK
WITH THREE D. PRINTERS
[inaudible]
FROM SUPPORT.
GROWING SHARMA STUDENT IT WOULD
HIGH SCHOOL IN ROCKLIN IN
SUPPORT.
ADAM KADMON OVER HALF OF EVERY
TIME FOR CONCEIVED IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MIKE MIKE LEAVITT
WITH GIFFORD LAW CENTER TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE MIGHT WANT TO TRY AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAKE SOME ROOM AT THE
DESK.
MAYBE IF IF.
ARE USED TO IT LIKE [inaudible]
SEVEN WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND RE
WITH NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
HERE IN OPPOSITION TODAY. TO
ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE THIS IS A
CONCEPT THAT'S COME UP BEFORE
AND AND CALIFORNIA'S HUNDRED
HOME TO HUNDREDS OF GUN LAWS.
INCLUDING RECENTLY ENACTED GOES
GUN LAWS A REQUIRES A PEOPLE TO
CONTACT THE OJ FOR SERIAL NUMBER
WHEN THEY'RE BUILDING A HOME
BILL FARM -- WE'VE HEARD THAT
THIS IS A LOOPHOLE AND OBVIOUSLY
CRIMINALS WHO ARE NOT OBEYING
THE MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED GUN
LAWS ARE.
NOT A ARE NOT PAYING ATTENTION
TO THIS ONE EITHER.
HOWEVER THIS BILLS GOT A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH IT AND HOW THE
PUBLIC'S GOING TO COMPLY WITH IT
AS WELL AS HOW IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING.
TO GOING TO AFFECT ITS RELYING
ON THE AMMO BACKGROUND CHECK TO
RUN THE BACKGROUND CHECK BECAUSE
YOU CAN UTILIZE THE NEXT SYSTEM
FOR THINGS THAT ARE NOT FIREARMS.
GROUND CHECK FOR AMMUNITION SET
TO GO INTO EFFECT JULY FIRST
IT'S AN UNPROVEN SYSTEM -- WE
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GONNA WORK AT
THIS POINT -- THURS SO A LOT OF
SPECULATION ON HOW.
WHAT KIND OF PROBLEMS WE MIGHT
BE FORCING WITH THAT AND I THINK
THAT THIS IS PREMATURE TO RELY
ON N THAT SYSTEM TO NOW?
INCLUDE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MILLIONS
MORE CHECKS AS WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE REQUIRING BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON ON PIECES OF METAL ON
PARTS -- AS YOU AS YOU HEARD
FROM -- THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ARE GONNA
BE TASKED WITH CREATING A
BOOKLET THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
PICTORIALS AND INFORMATION ON
HOW TO IDENTIFY THESE PARTS --
I'M VERY CURIOUS TO SEE THAT
WEEDS -- WERE STILL LOOKING FOR
A LOT OF GUIDANCE ON EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAWS INCLUDING --
CERTAIN THINGS WITH -- ASSAULT
WEAPONS AND SO NOW TO PUT THIS
GIANT TASK OF IDENTIFYING EVERY
HUNK OF METAL WHICH QUALIFIES AS
A PRECURSOR PART.
IS THAT IS GOING TO BE A
MONUMENTAL TASK AND I'D BE VERY
CURIOUS -- TO DISCUSS THE FISCAL
WHEN THAT BECOMES APPROPRIATE --
FURTHERS THERE'S OTHER ISSUES
LIKE ANTIQUE PARTS WHAT'S
EXCLUSIVELY FOR ANTIQUE FIREARM
AND HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
DISTINGUISH THAT.
AS WELL AS THE YOU KNOW THE THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM IS
PRECURSOR PARTS DO NOT HAVE ANY
IDENTIFYING MARKS ON ON THAT
LIKE A FARM WHERE IS A FIREARM
FRAME HAS A SERIAL NUMBER.
WHICH MAKES IT IDENTIFIABLE YOU
CAN SEE IF THE CHECKS RUN WERE
AS A PIECE OF METAL THAT.
THAT IS AN UNFINISHED FRAME
RECEIVERS NOT GONNA HAVE A PART
NUMBER ON IT OR MIGHT HAVE A
PART NUMBER BUT IT'S NOT GONNA
HAVE A SERIAL NUMBER YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO KNOW THE DATA
MANUFACTURING.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO KNOW ANY OF
THAT SO HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
KNOW IF SOMEONE BOUGHT IT BEFORE
THIS LAW INTO EFFECT WHETHER
IT'S BEEN SOMETHING.
THAT WAS PURCHASED AFTERWARDS
WHETHER THEY CAME IN FROM OUT OF
STATE HOUSES ACTUALLY TRULY
GOING TO BE ENFORCED -- I THINK
THAT THIS IS -- THIS IS STILL
PREMATURE I I THINK THAT
CRIMINALS ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO IGNORE THIS ALL LIKE THEY DO
THE HUNDREDS OF OTHER GUN LAWS
ON THE BOOKS.
WITH THAT WE STAND IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MYSTERIES.
MORE OF A GERMAN ROY GRIFFIS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION.
OUR MAIN CONCERNS AMERICAN OF
ECHO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SAID HE
COVERED IT WELL BUT OUR MAIN
CONCERNS ARE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE BEING ALREADY EXTREMELY
OVER TAX BY THEIR OWN TESTIMONY.
UNFUNDED WE HAVE OVER TEN
THOUSAND OUR PREDICT FELONS ON
OUR STREETS ALREADY THAT THEY
ARE OVER TASK AND DON'T HAVE THE
TIME TO ADDRESS THAT SITUATION.
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE
INAPPROPRIATE USING THE
SITUATION HAPPENED HERE AND
STOCK AMOUNT LAST WEEK I'M ALSO
A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THIRTY
TWO YEARS OF SERVICE TO THE
STATE.
KIND OF OFFENDED BY THROWING OFF
THROUGHOUT THEIR NAME TO BE USED
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE HAVE
NO IDEA WHETHER OR NOT -- THIS
LOBBYING AFFECT WOULD CHANGE
THAT SITUATION AS WE CAN
POSSIBLY THIS INDIVIDUALS ON THE
ON IT WOULD FELONS LIST.
AND HAD OR DOJ ASIANS HAVE THE
TIME TO DEAL WITH THAT.
MAYBE HE WOULDN'T HAVE FARMS AS
WELL SO WE COULD THROW ALL KINDS
OF SPECIALIZATION OUT THERE BUT
OUR MAIN CONCERN IS AGAIN TASK
IN THESE FOLKS IN THE OJ WITH
YET ANOTHER MANDATE.
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE THEIR TIME
AND ATTENTION AWAY FROM WHERE IT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE.
AND HAVING THESE PARTS OUT THERE
HAVING SOMETHING STERILIZED WITH
THIS NUMBER IN A FARM WITH
ANOTHER NUMBER.
REPLACEMENT PARTS ARE JUST GOING
TO CREATE A NEW ENFORCEMENT NICE
NIGHTMARE FOR THOSE REASONS ON
THE REASON MY COLLEAGUE OUTLINED
WEREN'T STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS REPRESENTING
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CAPULETS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
OUTDOOR SPORTS SINCE COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMAN'S.
INSPIRED CLUB INTERNATIONAL.
ALL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GOVERNOR'S
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
WITH THE CHAMBER -- TEMPLES ALL
OF THE HAVE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
APOLOGIZE I WAS DOWN IN ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY.
LOS ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THAT BRINGS US BACK TO THE ANY
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
I I JUST HAVE ONE AND AND THIS
YEAR I'VE BEEN ON SEPT FIVE FOR
THE FIRST TIME GETTING.
TO ENJOYED BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
PERSPECTIVE AND I'VE BEEN SORT
OF A MAYES SAID SOME OF THE
BILLS WE APPROVED IN HOW HOW
MUCH IT DOES COST -- TO
IMPLEMENT THEM SO I'M I'M JUST
CURIOUS -- WITH WITH THIS BILL.
I MISTER GRAHAM DO YOU HAVE ANY
SENSE ON IS IT WOULD REQUIRE IT
HIRING ADDITIONAL STAFF -- IS
THE CURRENT STAFF.
IT WOULD JUST FIT WITHIN THEIR
REGULAR WORK ASSIGNMENTS SO
WOULDN'T BE.
A BURDEN AT ALL TO TAXPAYERS.
IF I MAY ANSWER -- THE BILL IS
SOMEWHAT FORWARD LOOKING IN THE
ENSE THAT MOST OF MOST OF THE
ACTIVITY STARTS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THERE ARE
VARIOUS BILLS AS YOU SAID AT
THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED OVER THE
YEARS THAT.
THE I. T. SIDE OF DOJ -- ARE
ATTEMPTING TO CATCH UP WITH --
DEALING WITH AGE CHANGES IN AGE
REQUIREMENTS ETCETERA -- THIS
BILL IS -- NOT ONE THAT WOULD
HAPPEN RIGHT NOW.
AND THE AMMO CHECK SYSTEM AS I
SAID EARLIER WILL BE STANDING UP
IN A FEW DAYS -- THERE'S ABOUT
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW THIS ONE THE
SYSTEM WOULD STAND UP.
SO -- I PERSONALLY DON'T HAVE
ANY.
CONCERNS THAT OUR OUR IT SIDE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO GET IT
GOING IT'S GONNA BE VERY CLOSELY
MODELED AFTER THE AMMO SYSTEM.
WHICH HAS TESTED WELL -- YOU
KNOW BEHIND THE SCENES AND
INTERNALLY -- I'VE SEEN THOSE
TESTS -- SO I'M NOT AGAIN I'M
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT THE IF WE
CAN MAKE A A SYSTEM IS PROBABLY
GONNA BE 85% THE SAME -- WORK
JUST LIKE THE EMR SYSTEMS GOING
TO WORK.
SEC DO I HAVE A MOTION.
YOU HAVE A QUESTION [inaudible]
WELL.
THAT -- MITCHELL WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR YOUR QUESTION THANK YOU
ACCESS THE QUESTION AND YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR I YOU REMINDED
ME JUST NOW THE TRUMPS OF FIVE
AND ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
OPPOSITION STATED OUT OF CONCERN
FOR A LACK OF FUNDING FOR
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO DO THIS.
KIND OF WORK I RECALL WE
AUGMENTED ON THE DEPARTMENT
SALARY OF A SALARY WHO THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET -- DO YOU
HAPPEN TO RECALL THE AMOUNT OF
MINUTES FOR THE BASIS PROGRAM AS
A CERTIFIED MEMBER OKAY ALL
RIGHT.
I DON'T REMEMBER EITHER BUT I
KNOW IT WAS NOT [inaudible]
I VOTED FOR BILL -- ON THE SEX
OFFENDER LIST AND I WAS AMAZED
AT AS THE TTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE SHOWED US HOW.
MUCH IT'S COSTING ALL THE WORK
CAN I GET UP NOW MULTIPLE TIERS.
AND AND SO I WAS LIKE OH MY
GOODNESS I'M.
SORRY TO APPRECIATE.
WHAT WHAT A VOTE REALLY MEANS
AND SO THAT'S WHAT PROMPTED?
APPROPRIATELY SO BUT I I WASN'T
SO MUCH RESPONDING TO YOUR
COMMENT BUT TO TO ONE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE OPPOSITION WHO
WHO CLAIM THAT.
THEY WERE YOU KNOW UNDER BUDGET
AND WOULDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
THEMSELVES THAT'S WHAT TRIGGERED
MY MEMORY ABOUT ACTIONS WE DID
TAKE IN THIS BUDGET NOT WAS
HOPING YOU COULD REMEMBER THE
DETAILS AS A SUB FIVE MEMBER I
DON'T RECALL.
UNFORTUNATELY I CHAIR IS IN HERE --
BUT THE THE POINT I'M ATTEMPTING
TO MAKE IT MAY NOT BE TO YOUR
BIGGER PIC BIGGER STATEMENT
ABOUT.
FUNDING EVERY BILL BUT
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO THE
COLLECTION OF FIRE ARMS FROM
FROM INAPPROPRIATE PEOPLE WE DID
AUGMENT THE BUDGET THIS YEAR AS
WE HAVE IN PAST YEARS.
AS SENATOR NIELSEN REMINDS US
EVERY BUDGET HEARING WHEN WE
HEAR IT.
THAT WE'VE DONE THAT SO I JUST
WANTED TO FOR THE RECORD MAKE
THAT DECLARATIVE STATEMENT AND
SEEN NO OTHER MEMBERS.
WHO MAY BE INCLINED TO MAKE A
MOTION I'M OF THE BILL?
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE AP PS.
YEAH.
GREAT WE HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE --
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS AND MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORLOCK.
BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
MORALE.
WE WERE ALL NOW.
WIENER.
WE WILL KEEP THAT ON CALL IT HAS
A ONE VOTE AND WE WILL -- THANK
ROLE LATER THANK YOU.
THE SOONER WE GET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
THE GLAD YOU HAD.
ARMED SECURITY THIS TIME.
I WILL TAKE A SECOND TO ALLOW MR
GRAMM.
TO PACK UP.
AND THEN.
WE HAVE A ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
GREY YES -- CUNNINGHAM HOW HE
CAME BACK.
RACES BEEN WAITING ALL THIS TIME
CAN TAKE CUNNINGHAM.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A A RULE
MODIFICATION OR SOMETHING.
WELCOME THE SOME RETURNING HAVE
YOU HAVE -- TWO BILLS ONE WAS ON
CONSENT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED THANK YOU THE OTHERS AB
SIX SIX THREE ITEM.
ELEVEN WELCOME THANK YOU
SENATORS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
SIX SIX THREE AS THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS WE ARE FIGHTING A
WORLDWIDE FIGHT AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHICH IS THE FASTEST
GROWING.
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE IN THE WORLD.
I THINK ONE IMPORTANT COMPONENT
OF THAT FIGHT IS MAKING SURE
THAT WE PROVIDE.
REHABILITATION AND SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR THE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
I CAN TELL YOU AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR THAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS IT IS A CRIME.
THAT IT IS SERIOUS AND IN SOME
WAYS IT'S UNLIKE ANY OTHER --
THESE VICTIMS OFTEN NEED
COUNSELING THEY NEED RELOCATION
SERVICES THEY NEED A PLACE TO
STAY THEY NEED A SAFE HOUSE THEY
NEED.
A PROTECTIVE ORDERS THEY NEED
SUPPORT -- THAT'S THAT'S QUITE
EXPENSIVE FRANKLY -- ONE ISSUE
WE ARE SEEING IS THE WITH THE
STATE WIDE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND WHICH FUNDS MOST VICTIMS
SERVICES FOR GENERAL CRIMES --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- WE'RE
SEEING AN ISSUE WHERE THE
STATEWIDE VICTIMS COM FUND IS IS
UNDER FUNDED AND POTENTIALLY IS
GOING TO REACH A POINT OF
INSOLVENCY AT SOME POINT THE
NEAR FUTURE.
WHICH WILL REQUIRE BACK FILL
FROM THE GENERAL FUND OR SOME.
REMEDIATION OF THAT -- WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO DO WITH THIS BILL
WHAT I'M ASKING THIS COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER APPROVING?
IS SETTING UP A STANDALONE
FUNDING SOURCE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL FOR THE VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE WOULD DO THAT BY
TAKING 75% OF THE FINES PAID FOR
SOLICITATION.
HOW WHICH IS ALREADY CRIMES
STATUTES NON NEW CRIME -- WE
TAKE 75% OF FINES PAID BY THOSE
CONVICTED OF SOLICITATION -- WE
WOULD FINAL THAT MONEY INTO THE
TO THE COUNTY LET THE COUNTY
RETAIN THAT.
EXCLUSIVELY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THE VICTIM.
SERVICES WITH RESPECT TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS.
I JUST A FEW STATS TO CONSIDER.
JUST ON THE ON THE ON THE
ARGUMENT AND IN SUPPORT OF THE
ARGUMENT THAT -- THAT IS VERY
EXPENSIVE TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS OF
TRAFFICKING -- FOR A CHILD
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IT'S ESTIMATED THE AVERAGE COST
OF CARE.
IS AROUND SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH
WHICH EQUATES TO ABOUT SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR.
THAT'S FOR A CHILD EVEN AN ADULT.
VICTIM A TRAFFICKING THE AVERAGE
COST OF CARE IS ESTIMATED TO BE
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH --
THIS IS THIS IS.
AND EXPENSIVE ENDEAVOR BUT IT'S
AN IMPORTANT ENDEAVOR BECAUSE
THESE FOLKS REALLY NEED HELP --
TO BE ABLE TO REBUILD THEIR
LIVES.
OFTEN IN.
IN A COUNTY THAT THEY MAY OR MAY
NOT EVEN RESIDE IN.
I MEAN THERE TRAFFIC ON A
CIRCUIT IS WHAT WE'RE SEEING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- SO.
I THINK IT'S WHERE THE CHANGE IN
LINE I THINK GIVING THE COUNTY
LEVEL OF FUNDING INDEPENDENT
THAT IS RETAINED AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL WITH EASE SOME OF THE
PRESSURE ON THE STATE WIDE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION FUND A AND
B. GIVE OUR COUNTIES THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO TRY TO HELP
THESE VICTIMS.
OUT OF THE OF THIS HORRIBLE
CRIME AND WITH ADDED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY NO PROBLEM DON CAP KEY ON
BEHALF OF CRIME VICTIMS UNITED
CALIFORNIA ALSO SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTINE WAR CRIME
VICTIMS ACTION ALLIANCE AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DO I HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES.
DO I HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION DO I HAVE A
CLOSING STATEMENT.
I WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU THE SERVER CUNNINGHAM
MADAM SECRETARY FOR TO TAKE THE
ROLE.
QUESTION IS THE FASTER
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORLOCK I MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD
JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE.
ALL I WIENER.
SO AS TO BOTH SETTLE BE ON CALL
THANK YOU FOR COMING SERVER
CUNNINGHAM THAT BRINGS US NOW.
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB NINE ONE SEVEN
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
[inaudible]
SENATOR.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTEEN A BILL WHICH
UPDATES THE TIMELINE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND CERTIFICATION ENTITIES TO
PROVIDE THE PROPER DOCUMENTATION
TO THE VICTIM OF CRIME OR THEIR
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE PURPOSES
OF OBTAINING YOU VISA AND TV'S
THE CERTIFICATION.
A U. VISAS GRANTED TO VICTIMS OF
CRIME OR THEIR LOVED ONES WHO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND HAVE FULLY
COOPERATED WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ASSIST IN THE
PROSECUTION OF A CIMINAL CASE.
SIMILARLY THE TV'S THE ALLOWS
ELIGIBLE VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. TO TEMPORARILY
REMAIN AT WORK IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IN RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
ENACTED LEGISLATION TO ENSURE
YOU VIS A AND T. VISA APPLICANTS
HAVE RECEIVED CERTIFICATION FROM
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND FOR THOSE IN
REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS IN AN
EXPEDITED MANNER.
HOWEVER MANY IMMIGRATION
PRACTITIONERS AND DEPORTATION
DEFENSE HAVE EXPRESSED THE NEED
TO CREATE A CERTIFICATION
PROCESS THAT IS PARALLEL TO THAT
OF THE CURRENT IMMIGRATION COURT
SYSTEMS. TO FURTHER PROTECT
VICTIMS.
AB NINE SEVENTEEN SIMPLY
REQUIRES A CERTIFYING ENTITY TO
PROCESS VICTIMS CERTIFICATION
FOR EITHER OF THESE VISAS.
ON ONE OF TWO TIME LINES THIRTY
DAYS FOR MOST INDIVIDUALS AND
SEVEN DAYS FOR THOSE IN REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS DUE TO THE IMMEDIATE
SITUATION AT HAND.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT DURING THESE
TRYING TIMES CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANTS ARE
SUPPORTED.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORTOF
THE BILL IS CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH SHEILA AND
CENTER FLORIDA STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH HITLER.
GOOD MORNING MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CYNTHIA FLORENCE AND I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS SHE LAUGHED.
OUR LEGAL DEPARTMENT PROVIDES
REPRESENTS REPRESENTATION TO NON
CITIZENS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND NATURALIZATION
PROCESS FAMILY BASE ADJUSTMENTS.
VICTIMS OF CRIME AND INDIVIDUALS
FACING IMMINENT DEPORTATION.
I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF AB NINE SEVENTEEN FOR
TWO REASONS. TO ENSURE THE DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS OF IMMIGRANTS AND
TO EMPOWER CAL TO PROVIDE THE
BEST REPRESENTATION POSSIBLE
AGAINST DEPORTATION.
IT IS NO SURPRISE THAT POLITICS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL HAVE
CHANGED THE CLIMATE UNDER WHICH
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS PRACTICE
LAW.
WE FELT THIS CHANGE MOST IN
IMMIGRATION COURT.
IMMIGRATION JUDGES ARE UNDER
PRESSURE TO ADJUDICATE
ADJUDICATE AS MANY CASES IN A
SHORT OF A TIME WHEN IT'S
POSSIBLE.
NOW THAT IMMIGRATION JUDGES ARE
UNABLE TO ADMINISTRATIVELY CLOSE
CASES THIS MEANS THAT THERE ARE
LESS LIKELY TO CRACK
CONTINUANCES TO PRESENT
ANCILLARY FORMS OF RELIEF.
INCLUDING YOU AND TV SAYS THIS
IS AN THIS HAVE AN ADVERSE
EFFECT ON YOU AND TV SO
APPLICANTS.
WHO ARE BENEFICIARIES OF
COLLATERAL RELIEF IN IMMIGRATION
COURT PRACTITIONERS MUST WORK AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO SUBMIT
RELIEF IN ORDER TO DEMONSTRATE
TO THE IMMIGRATION JUDGE THAT
THESE FORMS OF RELIEF ARE VIABLE?
DEFENSES A DEPORTATION IN SHORT
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE WE CAN NO
LONGER DEPEND ON THE LUXURY OF
TIME TO HELP ADVISE THE BEST
STRATEGY TO DEFEND NON CITIZENS
FROM DEPORTATION.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE ASKING FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE
VICTIMS OF CRIME IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHAT'S WITH AXES TO
POLICE REPORTS OF CERTIFICATIONS.
THAT THEY MAY PURSUE COLLATERAL
RELIEF AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND DEFEAT THE THREAT OF
DEPORTATION FOR ALL THESE
REASONS DE LA IS A PROUD TO
SPONSOR OF AB.
NINE SEVENTEEN EVERY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU'RE ABLE.
THANK YOU MISTER FLORES MISTER
SANCHEZ CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH OF
pIMMIGRANT RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION BUT TO BE A SPONSOR
THIS MEASURE IN HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE SMITH CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP DONE THE MYSTIC
VIOLENCE AND SUPPORT.
ANDREA RIVER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE A CHAIR WITH ASIAN%
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
AMENDED WORK ON BEHALF SO YOU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WELCOME BACK MR CELL DILLON GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
KORI SAYS ELLO BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SURE SURE NOT OPPOSED TO THE UV
SO OR TV SO OR THE PROCESS --
THAT THE TEMPS TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF INVESTIGATIONS OR
THE ABILITY. FOR VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES TO BE PRESENT AND BE
THANK YOU BE PART OF THE PROCESS.
THE CONCERN WE HAVE IS IS
LARGELY INTIMATELY MORE ABOUT
EXISTING LAW WHICH PURPORTS TO
GIVE THOSE WHO ARE ASKED TO SIGN
THE CERTIFICATION THE DISCRETION
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THE VICTIM
WITNESS IS BEING COOPERATIVE.
AND THEN STATE LAW THAT
EFFECTIVELY.
MANDATES THE SIGNATURE ON THAT
CERTIFICATION FORM ALMOST
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE PERSON IS BEING COOPERATIVE
SO THE STATE LAW SAYS THAT.
A PERSON REQUESTED TO SIGN THE
CERTIFICATION FOR A TV SIR UV SO --
THERE'S A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
THAT THE PERSON IS BEING
COOPERATIVE UNLESS THERE IS
EVIDENCE THAT THEY'RE NOT BEING
COOPERATIVE AND SO IT'S A
DEFAULT THAT.
THIS FORM SHOULD BE SIGNED IN
THIS IF IF THE NOTION IS GOING
TO BE THAT THERE IS A PERSON.
AN OFFICIAL WHO IS MAKING A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THIS VICTIM OR WITNESS IS
BEING COOPERATIVE.
THE NATIONAL BE THE SOLE
PROVINCE OF THAT OFFICIAL IN THE
INSTANT PROCEEDING THIS BILL
SAYS THAT THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE
WHO CAN REQUEST THE
CERTIFICATION.
AND THAT -- THE TIME FRAME IS
SHORTER I UNDERSTAND THE
PROPONENTS ARGUMENTS ON WHY
THAT'S NECESSARY.
WE JUST HAVE SORT OF A
FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN ABOUT THE
PROCESS AGAIN NOT NOT WITH THE
NOTION OF PROTECTING THOSE WHO
ARE VICTIMS OR WITNESSES
CERTAINLY -- WE WANT TO PROTECT
THEM WE WANT -- TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH ANY -- ADMINISTRATIVE
ABILITY THAT THEY NEED TO FOR
THEM TO CONTINUE TO BE PART OF
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS OR ANY
CRIMINAL OR LEGAL INVESTIGATIONS --
BUT MANDATING THAT -- HERE BE
MORE PEOPLE WHO CAN ASK FOR THE
CERTIFICATION UNDER THE AUSPICES
OF THE EXISTING LAW THAT SAYS.
YOU EFFECTIVELY SHARE OF FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR POLICE
CHIEF YOU HAVE TO SIGN THIS
UNLESS YOU CAN SHOW ME THERE'S A
REASON WHY THEY'RE NOT BEING
COOPERATIVE AND SORT OF DISAGREE
WITH THAT THAT BALLOTS AND THAT
NOTION SO FOR THOSE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ALBUM.
THANK YOU ARE THERE.
GIVE ME ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES THE BILL I HAVE A
MOTION -- NO DISCUSSION --
CLOSING STATEMENT MISS REYES.
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN OUR AREA --
REGARDING AMENDMENTS THAT THEY
HAD REQUESTED SPECIFICALLY ON
DATE OF RECEIPT -- AND WHERE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM AND
ACCEPTED ACCEPTED SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS -- I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM OUR SERVICE
DEPARTMENT OR THE SHERIFF'S
REPRESENTATIVES.
BUT WE HAVE WORKING DILIGENTLY
IN THAT REGARD SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES --
AB SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL QUESTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORE LACKEY.
BRADFORD JACKSON FIVE JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL MORALE.
WIENER.
WE WILL HOLD OPEN THE ROLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEVEN A
REYES.
I YES.
THIS CALL WATER.
THE OTHER ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
A. B. TWO FOUR THREE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
THREE WELCOME [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
SENATORS.
APOLOGIES FOR THE DELAY.
I AM HERE PRESENTING AB TWO FOUR
THREE WHICH WILL REQUIRE PEACE
OFFICERS STANDARDS TRAINING OF
ALSO KNOWN AS POSED TO TRAIN
PEACE OFFICERS ON IMPLICIT BIAS.
EVERY TWO YEARS RATHER THAN THE
CURRENT.
FIVE WE COME TO TERMS WITH THE
FACT THAT EVERYONE HAS THEIR OWN
UNCONSCIOUS AN IMPLICIT BIAS
EVERYONE IS BY.
I AM.
TO I'M CONSCIOUS AN IMPLICIT
BIASES CAN AND DO AFFECT THE DAY
TO DAY DECISION MAKING PROCESS
SEES.
OF EVEN THE MOST FAIR MINDED
PEACE OFFICERS YET MORE
AWARENESS CAN COME THROUGH
EDUCATION INTERACTION AND
CONVERSATION.
DESPITE PEOPLE'S BEST INTENTIONS
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND THAT
SUBJECTS CAN CONSCIOUSLY EMBRACE
IDEAS OF FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY
AND YT.
ON TESTS THAT MEASURE SUB
CONSCIOUS TENDENCIES STILL SHOW
A STRONG PROPENSITY TO LEAN ON
STEREO TYPES TO FILL IN THE
BLANKS ABOUT PEOPLE THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT PEACE
OFFICERS RECEIVE MORE TRAINING
ON A ROUTINE BASIS TO RECOGNIZE
THEIR IMPLICIT BIAS EASE AND
TAKES STEPS TO COUNTERACT THEIR
UNCONSCIOUS INFLUENCES.
IT WILL TAKE MORE THAN OF COURSE
EVERY FIVE YEARS TO REYES
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS BUILT ON
HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF PERSONAL
AND INSTITUTIONAL RACISM THAT
HAS CREATED DEEP DIVISIONS IN
AMERICAN SOCIETY.
RESEARCHERS AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY EXAMINED ALMOST ONE
HUNDRED TRAFFIC STOPS FROM
200-011-22017 ACROSS TWENTY ONE
STATE PATROL AGENCIES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
AND MUNICIPAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS
INCLUDING BAKERSFIELD SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN DIEGO.
AND FOUND THAT BLACK AND LATINO
DRIVERS WERE STOP MORE OFTEN
THAN WHITE DRIVERS BASED ON LESS
EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING.
LOFT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
WIELD IMMENSE AUTHORITY IN I
BELIEVE THIS OBLIGATES THEM TO
BETTER COMBAT THEIR BIAS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
ALSO RECOGNIZES AND TAKEN
IMPORTANT STEPS TO DEAL WITH
IMPLICIT BIAS THAT AFFECTS OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES.
I WOULD LIKE TO BUILD A CULTURE
THAT CONSTANTLY AND RESPECTFULLY
ADDRESSES BIAS TO STRENGTHEN THE
TRUST BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
AB TWO FOUR THREE SIX TO AMPLIFY
THE DOJ'S WORK ON IMPLICIT BIAS
IN MANDATE THAT PEACE OFFICERS
MUST BE TRAINED EVER TWO YEARS.
TODAY WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS
KIMBERLY PAPPY ON JUDICIAL
PROFESSOR AND LISA HOLDER EQUAL
JUSTICE SOCIETY LEGAL DIRECTOR
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
MORNING SENATORS.
PLEASE HOLD A CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY AND UCLA LAW LECTURE ON
CONSTITUTIONAL POLICING.
AND I AM DRESSING ADDRESSING YOU
TODAY IN MY CAPACITY AS INTERIM
LEGAL DIRECTOR FOR THE EQUAL
JUSTICE SOCIETY.
AND OAKLAND BASS RACIAL JUSTICE
ADVOCACY GROUP. FOR TWENTY YEARS
THE EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY HAS
BEEN STUDYING IMPLICIT BIAS.
AND ITS IMPACT ON INDIVIDUAL
DECISION MAKING.
AND INSTITUTIONS.
AND HERE'S WHAT WE'VE LEARNED.
AS THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN SAID ALL
PEOPLE HAVE IMPLICIT BIAS WHICH
IS ALSO NOWN AS UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS.
AND THOSE BIASES DEVELOP OVER
THE COURSE OF A LIFETIME. TO
EXPOSURE TO STEREO TYPES OFTEN
RACIAL STEREOTYPES AND GENDER
STEREOTYPES.
INPUT THE BIASES INFLUENCE OUR
BELIEFS OUR ATTITUDES OUR
CONDUCT OUR DECISION MAKING.
IN A WAY THAT OFTEN RUNS COUNTER
TO OUR CONSCIOUS BELIEFS.
AND OUR CONSCIOUS VALUES WHICH
IS WHY THEY CAN BE SO
FRUSTRATING AND INSIDIOUS.
POLICE OFFICERS WITH WE TALKED
ABOUT THE HUMANITY OF POLICE
OFFICERS WELL POLICE OFFICERS
YES THEY ARE HUMAN.
TOO AND SO THEY TO HAVE IMPLICIT
BIAS.
STUDIES SHOW THAT WHEN PRIME TO
WITH BLACK FACES IN RELATIONSHIP
TO WHITE FACES JUST LIKE
CIVILIANS POLICE OFFICERS ARE
CONSISTENTLY MORE LIKELY TO
ASSOCIATE BLACK FACES WITH
CRIMINALITY. TO MISS IDENTIFY
COMMON OBJECTS AS WEAPONS AFTER
BEING SHOWN PHOTOS OF BLACK
FACES.
AND TO LABEL PHOTOS OF BLACK
PEOPLE AS THREATENING.
WHEN LEFT UNADDRESSED THE
IMPLICIT BIASES OF OFFICES
CONTRIBUTE TO STAGGERING RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN POLICING?
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN WHITES TO
BE STOPPED BY POLICE TICKETED.
AND SEARCH DURING A STOP.
AND UNARMED BLACK PEOPLE ARE
ALMOST THREE AND A HALF TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE SHOT BY POLICE
OFFICERS THAN ON ARMED WHITE
PEOPLE.
SINCE BIAS IS LEARNED OVER THE
COURSE OF A LIFETIME IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO UNLEARN IT.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WITH
TRAINING.
SYSTEM SYSTEMIC TRAINING.
CHANGE IS POSSIBLE.
COUNTER BY IS TREATING PROVIDES
PRACTICAL TOOLS TO HELP
PARTICIPANTS UNLEARNED
STEREOTYPES. TO RETRAIN THE
BRAIN TO DISRUPT STEREO TYPE.
BASED IMPLICIT ASSOCIATIONS AND
TO MANAGE THEIR BIAS.
COUNTER BY ITS TRAINING IN ORDER
TO BE EFFECTIVE MUST BE ONGOING
AND REOCCURRING. ONE CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF AB TWO FORTY THREE
IS THAT IT REQUIRES INTENSIVE
REOCCURRING TRAINING EVERY TWO
YEARS. ONE OTHER THING STRESSFUL
WORK ENVIRONMENTS STIMULATE BIAS.
THERE'S NO MORE STRESSFUL WORK
ENVIRONMENTS THAN BEING A POLICE
OFFICER.
INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO DO THE HARD
WORK OF DISRUPTING THEIR OWN
BIAS IN DECISION MAKING BUT
INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO WORK AT IT.
TO POLICE AGENCIES A TO CREATE
POSITIVE BEHAVIOR SUPPORT
STRUCTURES THAT DE STRESS THE
WORK FORCE AND ALLOW THEIR
OFFICERS TIME TO MAKE CAREFUL
AND DILUTES THE DELIBERATE
DECISIONS.
THE KEY TO DISRUPTING.
BIAS IN POLICING AND THESE
TRAININGS WILL HELP INSTITUTIONS
START TO CREATE THESE STRUCTURES
TO SUPPORT THEIR OFFICERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR HOLDER
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND A STING TO MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY POPPY ON MY OF
FORMAL TITLE IS JUDICIAL
PROFESSOR -- I TEACH UNDER OF
SCIENCE IN THE LAW.
AFFECT OF TRAINING DOES NOT JUST
OPEN MINDED ACTUALLY ALTERS
BEHAVIOR AND PERHAPS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY.
IT ACTUALLY CAN ALTER NARAL
PHYSIOLOGIC REACTIONS.
OF CRITICALLY FOR PICK FOR PEACE
OFFICERS -- IF IMPLICIT BIASES
HIGHER IN A PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL THERE'S ACTUALLY A
BRAIN REACTION THAT LINKS TO
THAT -- IF ONE HAS A
PARTICULARLY HIGH LEVEL OF
IMPLICIT BIAS LET'S SAY FRANCES
TOWARDS AFRICAN AMERICANS.
OR LET NEXT INDIVIDUALS WE FIND
THAT A PART OF THEIR BRAIN
CALLED THE AMYGDALA.
ACTIVATES WHEN THEY SEE FACES
THAT FIT THOSE PARTICULAR
IDENTITIES.
THE IMAGE WAS ACTUALLY THE PART
OF THE BRAIN THAT ALSO TURNS ON
WHEN YOU SEE A SPIDER OR SNAKE.
CONSIDER THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF
A JUDGE.
WHO IS MAKING A SENTENCING
DECISION OR PROSECUTOR WHO IS
MAKING A CHARGING DECISION IN
FACT REASONABLY ONE COULD ARGUE
THAT THROUGHOUT THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM?
SEEN AN INDIVIDUAL AND HAVE ANY
REACTION IN YOUR BRAIN IS IF
YOU'VE SEEN A SPIDER OR SNAKE
WHICH WILL INCREASE YOUR BEGINS
OF FEAR THREAD EXCITING AND
DISTRUST TOWARDS AN INDIVIDUAL.
COULD REASONABLY AND CONCEIVABLY.
ALTER YOUR DECISION MAKING WITH
REGARD TO THAT PERSON.
PERHAPS THAT IS IN MOST A STARK
RELIEF AND AND AND MOST CLEARLY
SEEN THOUGH WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE ACTIONS OF OUR PEACE
OFFICERS.
IF INDEED WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
NOTION OF SOMEONE HAVING OF YOUR
THREAD EXILED YOUR DISTRUST
REACTION TO ONE GROUP VERSUS
ANOTHER IN.
NUMEROUS ADDITIONAL STUDY
SHOWING THAT WE CN EVEN.
TRACK THAT BASED ON FACIAL
FEATURES.
SO THAT A PERSON WHO HAS A BIAS
AGAINST LET'S SEE AFRICAN
AMERICANS WILL BE MORE LIKELY --
IMPLICIT BIAS WILL BE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE THESE SPIDER
SNAKE LIKE BRAIN REACTIONS TO
SOMEONE WHO LOOKS FAR MORE LIKE
SHAQUILLE O'NEAL THAN MATT DAMON.
OTHER THAT NOT WITHSTANDING
THOUGH THIS NOTION IMPLICIT BIAS
IN THE SPECIFIC NOR REACTIONS
LINK DIRECTLY TO OUR STUDIES ON
BEHAVIOR THAT IS THE LIFE AND
DEATH DECISION MAKING CONTEXT
FOR PEACE OFFICERS. FOR INSTANCE
OF WHEN WE DO COMPUTER AYE
SIMULATION SIMULATIONS AND THEY
SHOW PEOPLE POPPING UP ON THE
SCREEN.
INDIVIDUALS OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND ANGLO AMERICAN DESCENT WHO
ARE EITHER HOLDING A WALLET A
CELLPHONE OR GUN.
WITH INSTANTANEOUS REACTION TIME
WE FIND THAT THE INDIVIDUALS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
WHO CHAU IMPLICIT BIAS AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO SELECT THE
OPTION SHOOT? FOR AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN MAN HOLDING A WALLET OR
CELL PHONE THREE TIMES MORE
LIKELY THAN THEY ARE FOR A
CAUCASIAN MAN HOLDING A GUN.
WE CAN ACTUALLY ON DO THIS.
THE THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE
NEUROSCIENCE PROVIDES US WITH
MUCH MORE THAN A HOLD HANDS SING
C° Y OUR OPEN MINDS AND HAVE A
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIP TYPE
COURSE WE CAN GO FURTHER THAN
THAT AND ALTER THOSE VERY BRING
REACTIONS.
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS
PROBLEMATIC AND THAT'S WHAT THE
NEUROSCIENCE SHOWS US WE CAN
LOWER THE LEVEL OF A MID
DELIVERY ACTION.
WE CAN ACTUALLY TURN ON THE
PARTS OF THE BRAIN THAT INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WE SEE THAT PEOPLE WILL GET MORE
ACCURATE IN SAYING SHOOT VERSUS
NO SHOOT WHEN FACED WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S HOLDING AN
OBJECT WE CAN LITERALLY INCREASE
THEIR LEVEL OF ACCURACY.
THAT'S WHAT TRAINING CAN DO.
OF COURSE THEM.
IN CALIFORNIA THE JUDGES RECEIVE --
TRAINING IN ETHICS ON A REGULAR
BASIS A KEY WE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
NUMBER WERE ON AT THIS POINT WE
TEND TO CALL IT -- AND AT THE
NATIONAL JUDICIAL COLLEGE A
TRAINING IS UPDATED ON A REGULAR
BASIS EVERY SINGLE TIME A CLASS
IS TAUGHT THERE IS AN UPDATE. TO
THAT PARTICULAR TRAINING SO WHAT
DAY DOES NOT SO MUCH A CONCERN.
IT'S JUST PART OF WHAT HAS TO BE
DONE -- PERHAPS THE MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHEN WANTING FUSES
SCIENCE.
IN INFORMATION AROUND DECISION
MAKING.
IT IS NOT IS IT IS NECESSARY TO
CONSTANTLY UPDATE.
ANYONE WHO WAS DOING THEIR JOB
WELL WE'LL KEEP UP WITH THE DAY
TO DAY INFORMATION THAT IS BEING
PUT OUT BY THESE NARAL
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES THE GIVES US
BETTER AND BETTER SOLUTIONS.
EACH AND EVERY TIME.
IT TAKES A WHILE TO RIDE A CLASS.
IT DOESN'T TAKE THAT LONG TO
UPDATE IT IF PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE SCIENCE.
ANY CLASS THAT YOU TAKE SHOULD
BE UPDATED ON A REGULAR BASIS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF CLASSICAL
ENGLISH LITERATURE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT -- ONE BUT
INDEED IF WE USE THE SCIENCE IF
WE USE THE TOOLS IF WE TRY TO
CREATE AN EFFECTIVE TRAINING
THAT WILL ALTER DECISION MAKING
ALTER BEHAVIOR.
AND ALTER NORMAL REACTIONS WE
CAN ACTUALLY CHANGE JUSTICE
OUTCOMES THROUGHOUT THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND PARTICULARLY
FOR PEACE OFFICERS THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
JUST COME UP TO THAT MAIN MIKE.
CHRIS FOR SIGNS OF A TRUE OTHER
CALLERS REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND DOUBLE ACP A SUPPORT.
AND ONE MATHIS WITH UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY AND ALSO HERE
ON SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
DEMOCRATS.
CALVIN QUICK BEERY SKIN ACTRESS
IN SUPPORT THIS IN SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
ALSO GIVE JUSTICE COALITION IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
MANY OTHERS.
RIGHT WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SCENE.
NINE DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BY MY COLLEAGUE THIS.
A SENATOR JACKSON.
THANK YOU -- WELL ARTICULATED
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE I
OF ON THE NEED FOR THIS BUT THE
THE HI I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH -- THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
WHO'S AN OLD FRIEND OF MINE AND
I THINK.
PRETTY PROGRESSIVE WHO ALSO
HAPPENS TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF
POST.
AND SO I ASKED HER WHAT SHE
THOUGHT OF THIS PROPOSAL TO MAKE
IT INSTEAD OF EVERY FIVE YEARS
EVERY TWO YEARS.
IN OUR FIRST RESPONSE WAS MIKE.
YOU KNOW SHE SHOULD WE DO UPDATE
THIS EVERY FIVE YEARS AND THIS
WOULD MAKE IT SO WERE IN
CONSTANT UPDATE MODE AND I HEARD
YOU SAYING YOU KNOW SCIENCE
KEEPS CHANGING.
WE LEARN MORE.
ON A REGULAR BASIS SHE SAYS SO.
IT IS THE FIRST FALL -- THE
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING IS
ALREADY OFFERED IN THE ACADEMY
SO AT LEAST WE GET STARTED
PEOPLE THINKING YOU KNOW THEY
MAY HAVE I MEAN EVERYBODY IS A
LITTLE BIAS.
IS A GREAT THE BROADWAY SHOW
CALLED -- AVENUE Q. AND A FAVOR
SO THERE'S A WONDERFUL SONG IN
THERE IT'S IS EVERYBODY'S A
LITTLE BIT RACIST AND THEY TALK
ABOUT HOW.
YEAH EVERYBODY DOES HAVE CERTAIN
PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS THAT ARE
NOT ACCURATE BUT BASED UPON LIFE
EXPERIENCE OR WHATEVER SO.
I START WITH THAT ASSUMPTION --
SHE SAYS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THE TRAINING IS ONLINE OR
AGENCIES PUT TOGETHER OF COURSE.
ON THEIR OWN.
OFFICERS ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO
TAKE BY ANDATE FIRST AID AND
CPR EVERY TWO YEARS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE EVERY TWO YEARS BLOOD
BORNE PATHOGENS EVERY TWO YEARS.
AND PURSUE DRIVING EVERY YEAR --
SHE SAYS THAT THE SHE BELIEVES
THAT THE TRAINING DEMANDS WERE
NOW PUTTING ON FOLKS -- MAKE IT
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO DO AND SHE
RECOMMENDED THIS IS WHAT I
WANTED TO ASK YOU.
THAT SHE SUGGESTED THAT WOULD
CONTINUE DOING THAT EVERY FIVE
YEARS AND FOCUSED INSTEAD ON DE
ESCALATION.
AND THE USE OF FORCE AT LEAST
FOR NOW SHE SAYS CONSIDERING THE
PROPOSAL OF THE PRESSURE.
THAT IS PUT ON POST AND ON THE
OFFICERS GIVEN ALL THESE THINGS
THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO.
SO WHAT MY QUESTION FOR YOU IS
GIVEN THE GIVEN THE ISSUES IN
THE PRIORITIES DO YOU THINK THAT
THEY SHOULD.
PREEMPT SOME THOSE ARE THE OTHER
ITEMS THAT WERE ARTICULATED OR
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
TRAINING THAT WE ACTUALLY.
EVEN THOUGH WE MUST DO IT THAT
REALISTICALLY WE CAN ALSO
REQUIRE EVERY TWO YEARS.
THAT TO ME SENATOR WITH THAT --
YES.
YOU YOU CAN RESERVE.
THANK YOU -- I RESPECT TO THE
NOTION THAT INDEED THERE ARE
SEVERAL COURSES THAT ARE PEACE
OFFICERS MUCH TAKE MUST TAKE.
THAT ARE -- RE UP EVERY TWO
YEARS SO TO SPEAK AND THE LIST
THAT YOU A NUMERATOR -- WAS OF I
THINK PARTICULARLY POIGNANT
BECAUSE THOSE ARE ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY IN A VERY REAL AND DIRECT
WAY -- IMMEDIATE PUBLIC SAFETY
IMMEDIATE DECISIONS THAT ARE
MADE AND STRESSFUL CONTEXT THAT --
AFFECT LIFE AND DEATH OF OUR
CITIZENS RIANA ME ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
I WOULD PLACE DISCOURSE IN THAT
SAME CATEGORY -- I WOULD SAY
THAT YES EVERYONE IS A LITTLE
BIT BIASED.
MONDAY BIAS MANIFESTS ITSELF IN
THE CLASSROOM WE HAVE GIVEN OUR
TEACHERS OF THE TOOLS OF A PIECE
OF CHALK.
WHEN IT?
MANIFEST ON THE BENCH WE'VE
GIVEN OUR JUDGES A GAVEL IN A
ROW.
BUT WHEN IT MANIFESTS IN THE
ACTIONS OF OUR PEACE OFFICERS
WE'VE GIVEN THEM A GUN.
WE MUST THEREFORE HOLD THEM TO A
HIGHER STANDARD.
WE MUST HOLD THEM. TO THAT
HIGHER STANDARD AND AT THE SAME
TIME SUPPORT THEM.
WITH A HIGHER LEVEL OF EDUCATION.
THE LUCKY THING IS THAT IN THE
PAST WE'VE CREATED THESE COURSES
BE AT THE KEY WE COURSES FOR THE
JUDGES IN THE JUDICIAL CONTEXT.
FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND OR
A POST WE'VE TYPICALLY CREATED
THEM WITH COMMITTEES WORKING
TOGETHER GATHERING INFORMATION
AND AND DELIBEATING OVER THE
PROCESS -- IF IF I'M SURE YOU'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THESE OF
COMMITTEES AND IT GOES BACK AND
FORTH IN THEIR TO DRAFT AND THEN
THERE'S REDRAFTED THEIR SUB
COMMITTEES AND IS CANCELED
MEETINGS AND IT DOESTAKE QUITE
SOME TIME.
THE NOTION IS THOUGH WITH
ACADEMICIANS AND EXPERTS ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT PROCESS.
IF IF EXPERTISE IS BROUGHT TO
BEAR AND THERE'S A REGULAR
UPDATING JUST THE WAY IT'S DONE
AT HE NATIONAL JUDICIAL COLLEGE
JUSTIN WAITED STUNT ANOTHER
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS WILL
GET HIGHER QUALITY PRODUCT.
AND THE LATEST INFORMATION
RARELY WILL YOU HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE THE NEW SCIENCE WILL COME
UP YOU'LL HAVE TO TAKE SOMETHING
OUT THAT IS INCORRECT.
RATHER WHAT YOU WILL FIND WITH
GREATER FREQUENCY NINETY PLUS
PERCENT USUAL FIND AN EVEN
BETTER SOLUTION.
EACH AND EVERY TIME YOU CONTINUE
TO PURSUE THE SCIENCE I THINK
OUR OUR PUBLIC DESERVES THAT.
I THINK OUR PEACE OFFICERS TO
DESERVE THAT BECAUSE THIS IS
ALSO ABOUT THEIR SAFETY THOSE
SAME STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT
PEOPLE ARE THAT ARE PEACE
OFFICERS ARE MORE LIKELY.
AND MORE QUICK TO SAY SHOOT FOR
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN HOLDING
A WALLET OR CELL PHONE.
ALSO SAY THERE ARE PEACE
OFFICERS DELAYED.
WHEN THEY ARE DECIDING WHETHER
OR NOT TO SHOOT AN ANGLO
AMERICAN MAN WITH A GUN THAT
PUTS OUR PEACE OFFICERS AT RISK
AS WELL?
SO FOR THEIR SAKE I THINK WHAT
WE SHOULD DO IS INCREASE THE
LEVEL OF QUALITY INCREASE THE
UPDATE INCREASE THE COMMITMENT.
I THINK WE'LL GET A BETTER
OUTCOME IN THE END.
MATT MAJORS FOLLOWERS THAT MAY.
SO YOU THE EXAMPLES YOU CITE ARE
EXAMPLES THAT COME UNDER THE
HEADING OF DE ESCALATION IN THE
USE OF FORCE.
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW THAT IS A
FOCAL POINT -- AND THE NECESSARY --
ONE AS WE ADDRESS POLICE OFFICER
TRAINING IT'S FEDERAL CHARTER SO
I AM.
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS.
IS THIS AN EITHER OR SITUATION
OR COULD WE INCORPORATE BIAS.
FOCUSING ON THE DE ESCALATION
AND USE OF FORCE ELEMENT RATHER
THAN -- BE TRYING TO CHEST.
CRANE ON THIS PARTICULAR GENERAL
I SUBJECT MATTER EVERY TWO YEARS
BECAUSE ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS IS THAT THERE MAY NOT
BE ENOUGH -- RESOURCES OR
WHATEVER YOU FOR THAT WOULD.
THAT MIGHT END UP TEACHING THE
SAME COURSE YOU MENTIONED IF WE
CAN UPDATE THEM THAT'S GREAT BUT
MIGHT END UP OFFERING THE SAME
COURSE YOU'RE AFTER WHICH WE
DON'T WANT.
SO I'M NOT WORRIED BEFORE YOU
RESPOND AS IF WE COULD --
BRIEFLY ON THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR -- IF THIS TRAINING
WERE TO SIMPLY BECOME AN AD
JUMPED ONTO THE ESCALATION IT
WOULD LIKELY LOSE ITS EFFICACY.
OF THE NOTION OF TEACHING.
DE ESCALATION -- AND THEN ADDING
ON THE NOTION OF IMPLICIT BIAS
WOULD NOT COMPLETELY SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THE SCINCE WILL SHOW
THAT WHILE YOU CAN TEACH PEOPLE
TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR IN GENERAL
AND THEN MENTION -- YES AND
LET'S TRY TO BE FAIR THAT
DOESN'T ALTER THE INEQUITY IN
THE ACTUAL BEHAVIOR SO THE
PROBLEM IS NOT SIMPLY WE NEED
OUR PEACE OFFICERS TO DE
ESCALATE ACROSS THE BOARD.
THE PROBLEM IN MANY WAYS AS WE
NEED THEM TO RECOGNIZE THAT THEY
HAVE MORE TROUBLE DE ESCALATING
IN THIS ARENA AND THEN GIVE THEM
THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED WHICH
REQUIRES MORE THAN JUST.
AND FUSE IT IN HERE WITH A FEW
ADDITIONAL POWER POINTS.
GIVEN THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
NEED TO ACTUALLY ALTER THEIR
BEHAVIOR WITH REGARD TO THAT
PARTICULAR TYPE OF BIAS.
THANK YOU FOR SHIP.
pI APPRECIATE THE BILL I DO M..
I CAN'T IMAGINE AS WAS A
REFERENCE SOME CONCERN ABOUT THE
EVERY TWO YEARS BECAUSE WHILE I
THINK ALL OF US CAN --
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THIS.
THE VALUE OF THIS TRAINING WE
ALSO KNOW THAT -- WHATEVER
GOVERNMENT AGE EVERYTHING IS IT
THAT THE THAT THAT FREQUENCY BUT
pSOMETIMES BUT I THINK THAT AS
YOUR WITNESS CHARACTERIZED.
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS A LIFE OR
DEATH SITUATION AND A LIFE OR
DEATH SITUATION AS MUCH FOR A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
BECAUSE AS I WAS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH THE REFERENCES WHICH I
THINK -- WE WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
DATA KNOW TO BE TRUE.
THAT THE THAT THESE BIASES WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR CULTURE WE
ALL HAVE THEY'RE NOT UNIQUE AND
THEY'RE NOT LIKE ONLY ONE RACE
HAS THE HAS THE BIAS -- IT'S
BASICALLY SO INGRAINED THAT WE
THAT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
THEMSELVES PUT THEMSELVES AT
RISK.
WHEN THEY HESITATE?
IF IT WERE IF THEY SEE A WEAPON
IN ONE CIRCUMSTANCE BUT OVER
COMPENSATE EVEN WHEN THEY DON'T
SEE A WEAPON IN A DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCE SO I I THINK THAT
THIS IS VERY COMPELLING -- AND
I'M SURE AS YOU GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS I KNOW THAT YO'RE
YOU'RE REALLY ONLY OF PROBES AND
THEN -- FLOOR BUT IF THERE ARE
REAL CONCERNS AROUND THE TWO
YEARS THAT WILL BE ADDRESSED --
OTHERWISE I THINK THERE'S A
VALUE TO THE FREQUENCY SO --
WITH THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE'VE GOT A MOTION AND WILL DO A
ROLL CALL BUT OF COURSE WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN BECAUSE WE
HAVE -- MEMBERS ARE ABSENT BUT
CENTER MORE LIKE DID YOU WANNA
MAKE A COMMONER.
I I I HAVE LITTLE DIFFICULTY
WITH THE EVERY TWO YEARS MAYBE
EVERY THREE FOUR I'D BE A LITTLE
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
[inaudible]
AT OR ADRIN M..
WE'LL DO THE ROLL CALL.
CLOSE -- I'M POLICIES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THE BILL AUTHOR PLEASE MAKE YOUR
LIFE THANK YOU AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND THE
CONVERSATION IN THE DIALOGUE --
THIS BILL REALLY JUST CREATES A
STANDARD AND SO WHEN HEARING IN
THE LANGUAGE THERE IS SOME
FLEXIBILITY NOT AROUND THE TWO
YEARS BUT THERE IS FLEXIBILITY
IN HOW THE CURRICULUM CAN BE
REFRESHED AND ADAPTED.
AND ALSO HOW THEIR SOME
OPPORTUNITIES -- FOR MORE
INTEGRATED -- KIND OF COURSE AT
THE I AND I THINK WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BIAS WERE
GENERALLY THINKING ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE PUBLIC.
IT'S ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT THE BIAS THAT
HAPPENS WHICH WITH IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITIES WE KNOW
THAT -- YOU KNOW THERE IS NO
THERE ARE VARYING DEGREES OF
EDUCATIONAL LEVELS -- THAT WE
SEE IN OUR POLICE OFFICERS
BEFORE THEY DECIDE TO GO TO THE
ACADEMY TO GET TRAINING AND WHEN
THEY'RE GOING INTO THE ACADEMY
TO GET TRAINING MOST OF THAT IS
PREPARING ON THEM TO ACTUALLY DO
THAT JOB.
NOT NECESSARILY TALKING ABOUT
BIAS.
AND I THINK THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AS WE LOOK AT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE AND THE
DIVERSITY OF THEMEMBERS THAT
ARE ARE SERVING AND PROTECTING
US.
I THINK ALSO THAT DE ESCALATION
IS ACTUALLY COUPLED WITH
IMPLICIT BIAS I DON'T THINK YOU
CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION AROUND
DE ESCALATION USE OF DEADLY
FORCE WITHOUT REALLY HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE TRIGGERS
THAT MIGHT BE IMPACTING HOW LAW --
HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW?
REACTING IN INTERACTING WITH
FOLKS IN THOSE MOMENTS AND SO MY
HOPE IS THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE
INTEGRATED.
AND LESS BLAME ORIENTED
CONVERSATIONS AS WE TRY TO
TACKLE THE VARIOUS ISSUES THAT
WE'RE SEEING -- ON THE STREETS
AS IT RELATES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN OUR COMMUNITY I THANK YOU FOR
THE CONVERSATION AND THE
CONTINUE DIALOGUE I DO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
RIGHT WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE MORLOCK.
BRADFORD.
JACKSON LIKE JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL MORALE [inaudible]
NO WIENER.
WILK M. KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AND
ARE ABSENT MEMBERS WILL RETURN.
AND NOW I SEE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA I BELIEVE THIS NEXT
AND THAT IS FOR AB [inaudible]
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO WELCOME.
THE CASHIER SENATORS OF THE
OPTIONS ON THIS BILL FOR YOU
TODAY.
AB TWENTY TWO PROHIBITS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION FROM
ASSISTING OR ALLOWING PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS TO ARREST.
DETAIN OR OTHERWISE TAKE INTO
CUSTODY INDIVIDUALS IN STATE
CUSTODY FOR IMMIGRATION PURPOSES.
IT WOULD ALSO CUT BY REGULATIONS
ADOPTED BY THE CDC ARE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH
PROHIBIT THE DETENTION OF
INDIVIDUALS BEYOND THEIR PRISON
TRYING TO ALLOW FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS TO TAKE
INDIVIDUALS INTO CUSTODY.
ADDITIONALLY WOULD ALSO CUT BY
THESE -- THESE REGULATIONS BY
BENDING CITIES ARE FROM TRANSFER
AND IMAGE OTHER STATE PRISON
WITHIN NINETY DAYS.
OF THE PERSON'S RELEASED A THIS
BILL IS IN DIRECT RESPONSE THE
PEDAL MINISTRATIONS MASS
ATTENTION AND DEPORTATION
STRATEGY WHICH INCLUDES THE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY CALPERS TO
UNLOCK THE CONSCRIPT.
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS INTO
IT'S A FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT STRATEGY.
THESE EFFORTS ARE IN DIRECT
CONTRAVENTION OF ESTABLISH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW AS WELL AS
WELL ESTABLISHED LEGAL PRECEDENT.
FEDERAL LAW IS CLEAR UNDER THE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION NATIONALITY
ACT UNLICENSED LAW ENFORCEMENT
NOT AUTHORIZED TO ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAW.
THIS INCLUDES PRIVATE SECURITY
COMPANIES.
THIS MEASURE TAKES IMPORTANT
STEP OF MEASURING THE CDC ARE
COMPRISED OF FEDERAL LAW BY
PROHIBITING PRIVATE SECURITY
CONTRACTORS ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA
PRISONS.
AND ENSURES THE DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS OF LAWFULLY LEASE IMAGE
OR NOT BY THE WOULD BE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT ARMENIAN NORM YOU'RE
A COACH I'M A FELLOW AT ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE.
AND PAUL SUCKED.
DIRECTLY IMPACT ORGANIZER
THERE'S BEEN PARDONED WITH THE
YOU JUST COALITION AND I ALSO
HAVE TO BE ANGELES CHAN.
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AND POLICY
DIRECTOR ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JOSH JUSTICE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING HI MY NAME IS
NEAR NOR AND I CURRENTLY LIVE IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I WORK WITH ASIAN LAW CAUCUS
AND I AM ALSO A A DAUGHTER OF
THE CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE SURVIVOR
AND REFUGEE.
AND I ALSO AM A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR AND SEXUAL
ASSAULTS BARBER AND ALSO FOR THE
CARS WHAT IT COMMITTEE MEMBER.
SERVE SIXTEEN YEARS AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY IN
CHOWCHILLA CALIFORNIA.
AT EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD I AM MADE
OF FAITHFUL UNFAITHFUL DECISIONS
THAT LED TO MY INVOLVEMENT IN
THE CRIMES THAT I WAS ORIGINALLY
SENTENCE OF LIFE WITHOUT THE
POSSIBLE ROLE.
I WAS SENTENCED TO DIE IN PRISON
FORTUNATE FOR ME FIVE YEARS
LATER THE COURT OF APPEALS BUT
TOOK MY A A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE A
TO CONSIDERATION AS ON AS A
MATTER THAT INVOLVED TO MY CRIME
AND MIGHT THE CONVICTION WAS
OVERTURNED.
A FORTUNE FOR ME I HAVE THE
CHANCE -- TO FACE PRO ABOARD
ENTER MY TIME IN PRISON I TOOK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXAMPLE TO OR
MY COLLEGE DEGREE -- RECEIVE
SELF NUMBER SELF HELP -- CLASSES
IN RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS
AND AS WELL AS BUT OCCASIONAL
EDUCATIONAL -- THAT WERE
AFFORDED TO ME. TO INCREASE MY
JOB SKILLS.
AND AFTER FIFTEEN HAVE YEARS
LATER I WAS FINALLY FOUND
SUITABLE BY THE PAROLE BOARD.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF MY
CONVICTIONS I DO FACE DE
DEPORTATION.
AND THE POOR RECOMMENDED MY
RELEASE HOWEVER I WAS TOLD WEEKS --
THAT BY PULL BY A ON PRISON
OFFICIALS THAT I WOULD -- BE UP
MOST LIKELY PICKED UP MY EYES.
SO THAT FOR ME WAS REALLY OF
DRAMATIC BECAUSE I FIGURED WHAT
WITH MY CHANCE WOULD BE IF I
WOULD GET DEPORTED BECAUSE
AMERICA'S OWN HOLD UP HOME THAT
I'VE KNOWN SINCE I WAS FIVE
YEARS OLD.
AND ALSO WHAT WITH THE
CONDITIONS WOULD BE LIKE AN ICE
DETENTION FACILITIES I WAS NOT
ABLE -- TO FIND JOY THAT I WOULD.
BE HOME IN AMERICA AND BE ABLE
TO LOOK FORWARD FOR MY RELEASE
PLAN AS WE ENTER BASS THAT WAS
NOT NOT PORTED TO ME.
AND I WAS PICKED UP.
A DAY THAT -- WITHOUT SCHEDULE
FOR ME TO BE PICKED UP AND WITH
THREE OTHER OF MY PEERS THERE
WERE INSIDE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO YOU KNOW
ONCE THEY GOT OUT TO BE REUNITED
WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
AND LO AND BEHOLD A ON A MALE.
OF OFFICER WHERE BLUE UNIFORM
CAME AND AND HE OP ROUGHLY TOLD
ME.
TOO FACE THE WALL ARE PUT MY
LEGS APART MY HAS IN THE AIR
TAKE MY SHOES.
AS I FELT REALLY.
EMBARRASSED BECAUSE AS I LOOKED
MY PARENTS WERE LOOKING AT ME
AND IT WAS THE SILENT THIS
MOMENT OF SILENCE LIKE THE
UNDERSTOOD I FELT VERY
DISTRESSED.
ON THE D. OF OFFICERS THEY
LOOKED AT ME AND THAT I'VE KNOWN
FOR YEARS AND THEY WERE KIND OF
IN SHOCK AS WELL THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING.
AN ARTICLE COULD DO WITH ARMY
TOLD ME TALK TO REMAIN SILENT ON
NOT TO SAY ANYTHING.
AND AGAIN AND THIS THIS REMINDED
ME OF WHEN I FIRST WAS ARRESTED
GOING THROUGH THE WHOLE PROCESS
ALL OVER AGAIN AND WE ARRESTED
AND AGAIN I WAS REALLY LIKE
MORTIFIED.
AS I WAS -- ESCORTED BY HIM INTO
A I'M MARK WHITE AS FAN ON GIVEN
FOR ABOUT AN HOUR.
AND THEN I WAS -- HOURS LATER
TRANSFERRED BY TWO OTHER --
AGENTS -- TO YOU BUT COUNTY
FACILITY.
WHERE I SPENT SIX MONTHS
FIGHTING DEPORTATION AND
FORTUNATELY FOR ME THE COMMITTEE
CAME THROUGH FOR ME?
AND FOR MYSELF HAVING WENT
THROUGH THE LEGAL SYSTEM HAVING
WITH THROUGH THE PRISON SYSTEM
ANY TENSION I DON'T WANT ANYBODY
TO EXPRESS WHAT I'VE WENT
THROUGH -- AND I REALLY HOPE
THAT YOU WOULD SUPPORT THIS BILL --
TO END THE PRIVATIZATION OF
PRIVATE ICE CONTRACTORS AND TO
FOR THIS UP YOU KNOW.
MAY BE ABLE FOR POLICE TO EUROPE
YOU MIGHT FALMOUTH AND FOCUS ON
THE PRO PADS INSTEAD OF HAVING
TO FACE IN A WHAT I WOULD
THROUGH AND MANY OTHERS SAYS
WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BOB GOOD MORNING GOOD LUNCH UP
ALSO WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION ALSO DIRECTLY IMPACTED
MYSELF.
ARE MUCH LIKE DNIA I WAS BORN IN
A REFUGEE CAMP A TIME AND CAME
HERE WAS BROUGHT HERE IT'S AN
INFINITE.
MOM GREW UP HERE LOST MY PARENTS
UNFORTUNATELY I BECAME PARALYZED
AT SIXTEEN ARM OUT A SINGLE
FATHER PASSED AWAY.
OUR WATER BEING TRIED AS AN
ADULT I SEVENTEEN SENT OFF THE
STATE PRISON COMMON
THEORETICALLY I JUST TO BE IN
PRISON TODAY BUT BECAUSE OF A
BILL TO CAME OUT OF THIS HOUSE
SB TO SIXTY HOURS ONE THE FIRST
PEOPLE I GOT UNDER SB. TWO SIXTY
ONE OF THE VERY FIRST ONES MAMA
FORTY DOES MUCH LIKE HEARD WHEN
IT WAS MY TIME TO ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IT WASN'T LEAVING.
IT WAS BEING PLACED INTO A TANK
WITH ARMED SECURITY GUARDS
COMING IN FROM G. FOUR S. THERE
WAS AN ICE AGE AND I WAS
EXPECTING AN ICE AGE I DIDN'T
SEE ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
BOB WAS ALWAYS CDC GUARDS AND A
SECURITY GUARD NAY TOLD ME TO
GET UP ON THE WALL.
JACK WAS ON MY CHANGE IN WAYS
AND AT LAKE AREN'T ON MY FEET SO
AND I'M WALKING OUT AS I WALKED
OUT I SEE THEM HAVING MY PRO
PAPERS TO SECURITY AGENT.
AND I SEE OTHER PEOPLE ACTUALLY
WALKING HOME WITH THEIR BAG OF
TO GET MONEY.
ON MY SIDE AND HAVING TO GET
MONEY I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING AND
OFF I WENT INTO THE NICE TOUCHES
CENTER FROM THERE.
THE SECURITY CONTRACTORS CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT I WAS GOING WHAT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO COULD
TELL ME TO DO SUCH AS ICE WHEN
YOU GET TO WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
MOM AND ENDED UP IN ANOTHER FOR
PROFIT SYSTEM AND EVERY
ENVIRONMENT AND EVERY SINGLE
ACCOUNT AROUND THERE WAS MORE
PROFIT BUSINESS.
YOU KNOW SHOULDN'T BE OUR MEANS
A PROFIT MAKING MONEY OFF
PEOPLE'S ON MISFORTUNES FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS SOLELY BECAUSE
THEY WERE BORN HERE -- INTO A
LOT OF US A LOT OF MY PEERS
ALREADY DEPORTED UNFORTUNATELY
THOUGH ALSO IT WOULD BE GREAT SB
TO SIXTY CANDIDATES AS WELL.
ON BOTH FORTY FOR ME BECAUSE OF
WORK I'VE BEEN DOING A COMMUNITY
SAID ABOUT GOVERNOR BROWN CAME
APART AND THAT'S THE ONLY REASON
MY DEPORTATION CASES CLOSE
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON IF NOT
FOR THAT.
AND THE WORK OF OTHER
LEGISLATORS AT CENTER THAT WAS
APPOINTED ME IN THAT BECAUSE I
WOULD NOT BE HERE TODAY.
SO ARTS AND I VOTE
OR PROP
COSPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANDRE RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT. ONE MENTOR
RANGER WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSE OF THE TRAILER
THE COLLEGE REMAIN IN YOUR
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NINETEEN NINE IT IS -- ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
NIGHT.
I'M BEFORE YOU CLOSE.
FAMILY MEMBER CAR I WANTED -- TO
THANK YOUR WITNESSES FOR BEING
WILLING TO COME AND SHARE.
THEIR EXPERIENCES -- IT TAKES A
LOT OF COURAGE -- AND WE DO HAVE
A VERY -- STOCK SYSTEM RIGHT NOW
UNFORTUNATELY FOR OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY AND WHILE THIS BILL IS
NOT GOING [inaudible]
TO COMPLETELY -- UP IN SOME OF
THE FEDERAL POLICIES THAT HAVE
PUT.
BOTH OF YOU AND OTHERS IN REALLY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES I THINK
IT.
IS A FIG GOOD.
REFORM INAPPROPRIATE FOR
CALIFORNIA SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL -- I WONDER IF THERE'S
A MOTION -- FOR WILL NEED TO
WAIT TILL ANY OTHER OF OUR
COLLEAGUES RETURN -- WE MAY NEED
TO WAIT TO HAVE OUR COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE PRESENTING ANOTHER
COMMITTEES RETURN BUT YOU.
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR I ALSO WANT TO THANK
OUR WITNESSES IS LOCAL.
VERY PERSONAL STORIES -- THAT --
REFLECT WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY AND IT REALLY IS
SIMPLY CODIFYING EXISTING
FEDERAL LAW AS WELL AS
REGULATIONS AT CDC ARE
REGULATIONS BATTERS BUT YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE AT OTHER COMMITTEES NOW
WILL RETURN.
SO -- AT THAT POINT WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AND WE'LL SEE
WHAT.
THANK YOU SO PRECIADO YOUR
PRESENTATIONIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WE NOW HAVE A BILL AB
TWELVE NINETY FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LIKE
PRESENT BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE NINETY FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE NINETY FOUR IS REALLY AN
EXTENSION OF A BILL THAT WE DID
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THAT.
PASSED WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THOSE ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTY NINE REALLY AIMED AT
ILLEGAL GAMBLING WHAT WE WERE
FINDING IN OUR COMMUNITIES WERE --
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL GO INTO.
A REAL ESTATE PROPERTY RIGHT A
LITTLE BUSINESS SMALL SMALL
SHOPPING CENTER SET UP A BUNCH
OF LAPTOPS THAT A PRIVILEGE
COMPUTERS RONALD ILLEGAL GAMING
AND THEN IF SOMEBODY ACTUALLY
ONE THEY WOULD JUST.
DECLARE BANKRUPTCY AND THEN MOVE
ON RIGHTS NOBODY EVER GOT PAID
OUT AND WE ACTUALLY FOUND UP AND
DOWN THE STATE THAT A LOT OF
THESE PLACES WERE ACTUALLY
FRONTS FOR THINGS LIKE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING -- THEY WERE FRIENDS
FOR DRUGS.
THE GAMING WAS OBVIOUSLY ILLEGAL
WE PASSED LEGISLATION THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED IT -- TO
ACTUALLY GO AFTER THESE
FACILITIES TO SHUT THEM DOWN
LOCAL CITIES AND MUNICIPALITIES.
OUT WHEN AND TRY TO SHUT THEM
DOWN -- BUT I GUESS WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW WITH THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY FOUR
IS A FURTHER EXTENSION OF THAT
WERE WE ALLOW ASSET FORFEITURE.
WE CAN ACTUALLY GO IN AND SEASON
ACTUALLY FREEZE -- THE MONEY AND
SO THIS IS REALLY YOU KNOW WE
WERE PLAYING WHACK A MOLE.
SINCE WE PASS A FOR FIRST PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND NOW THIS ONE
IS ACTUALLY TO TO REALLY GO IN
AND ACTUALLY SHUT THEM DOWN AND
THIS IS ONLY AIMED AT THAT IT
LEGAL GAMING -- THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING UP AND DOWN THE
INTERSTATE.
SO WITH THAT I DO HAVE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT FROM DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THROUGHOUT OUT
TO PAID WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE I'M HERE TODAY
WITH PARRIS MOTTA.
WHO IS A DEPUTY DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL -- WHO IS ALSO AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS?
A CHANGEOVER SERRA IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR A
BILL THAT STRENGTHENS THE DOJ'S
IN OTHER LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
ABILITY AGENCIES ABILITY TO
BRING STRONGER ENFORCEMENT.
ACTIONS AGAINST ILLEGAL GAMBLING
OPERATORS THE AMERICAN GAMING
ASSOCIATION ESTIMATES THAT THE
SEGMENT OF THE LEGAL GAMBLING
INDUSTRY KNOWN AS THE
SWEEPSTAKES CAFE INDUSTRY.
WHICH IS THE SUBJECT OF THIS
BILL COLLECTS MORE THAN TEN
BILLION A YEAR IN ILLEGAL
PROCEEDS.
THESE UNLAWFUL GAMBLING
OPERATIONS ARE LOCATED IN STORE
FRONTS AND STRIP MALLS AND
COMMERCIAL DISTRICTS OF CITIES
AND TOWNS ALL ACROSS THE UNITED
STATS INCLUDING.
MANY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
ADDITIONALLY THESE OPERATE
OPERATIONS ACT AS MAGNETS IN
INCUBATORS FOR OTHER CRIMES
INCLUDING DRUG SALES AND VIOLENT
FELONIES.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO WOULD
ALLOW DOJ AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO SEE THE
ILL GOTTEN GAINS FROM ILLEGAL
GAMBLING OPERATIONS THAT ARE
HELD IN BANK ACCOUNTS?
THE BILL CHEESES BY EXPANDING
THE DEFINITION OF CRIMINAL
PROFITEERING ACTIVITY TO INCLUDE
THE OPERATION OF THE LEGAL SLOT
MACHINES.
AND GET AND GAMBLING DEVICES
THIS ALLOWS FORFEITURE
PROCEEDINGS TO BE INITIATED
AGAINST THESE ILLEGAL OPERATORS.
AND ALLOWS YOU JAY AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO FREEZE
THE BANK ACCOUNTS THAT CONTAIN
THOSE ILL GOTTEN GAINS UNTIL A
JUDGE MIGHT A FORFEITURE IS.
ENTERED THIS BILL DOES NOT APPLY
TO TRIBAL CASINOS AND LEGALLY
OPREME CALIFORNIA CARD ROOMS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
CERTAINLY ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS COURCELLES
ALONE BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATHIS AND HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
MANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
FORTUNATE -- COMMENT SIR.
A LITTLE BIT GREAT WE HAVE A
MOTION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE WE KNOW WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO CURB THESE ILLEGAL
SWEEPSTAKES GAMING'S WITHOUT A
PROBLEM IN THIS IS. TO PUT A
NAIL IN THE COFFIN I GUESS.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AM I
APPRECIATE THAT THE BILL IS
NARROWLY CONSTRUCTED.
AND ARE WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY THANK YOU
WE'VE GOT A MOTION SO WE'LL DO A
ROLL CALL AND OF COURSE WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN BECAUSE WE
HAVE SOME ABSENT MEMBERS BUT WHO
WITH A WILL RETURN.
GO AHEAD PREVENTION IS THE
FASTER APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER
AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
OR LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
THE BILL -- BILLS I CALL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANKS SO
MUCH [inaudible]
AND NOW.
WORRY ARE IN NEED OF AN AUTHOR
[inaudible]
YEAH. ONE CONSEQUENCE STUFF.
WHERE WE CAN WAIT YEAH?
YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH WE'LL DO IT
ONCE.
OKAY WILL WAIT FOR OUR MISSING
AUTHORS.
FINISHED WITH BREAKFAST
X.
WELCOME.
WE WILL NOW HEAR ITEM TWENTY
YOUR BILL AB -- SIXTEEN OH THREE
CENTERS.
THIS BILL BASICALLY TAKES CALVET --
ARE CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PREVENTION PROGRAMS
AND CREATES A STATUTE FORTIN
PUTS IT IN THE STATUTE.
YOU KNOW THESE PROGRAMS ARE
EVIDENCE BASED WE KNOW THEY WORK
THEY TARGET THE COMMUNITIES THAT --
ARE EXPERIENCING THE MOST
VIOLENCE -- INVEST IN THIS
COMMUNITIES WE'VE SEEN A GREAT
SUCCESS I KNOW IN OUR SHARED
DISTRICT -- IN TERMS OF THE
REDUCTION OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
OAKLAND -- DUE TO USE A LIFE AS
WELL AS THE ORGANIZATION IN
RICHMOND VANCE PEACE WHICH
REALLY WORKS TO INVEST THE
COMMITTEES AND REALLY TO STOP
THE VIOLENCE FORT STARTS --
WE'VE WE'RE THRILLED THAT THE
BUDGET -- CONTAIN MORE RESOURCES
FOR THIS -- WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT A SENATOR AND WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE --
CAN WE KNOW THESE PROGRAMS WORK
LET'S PUT IT SAID SHE LET'S STOP
THE GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY BUT MISTER TESTIFIED.
FOR IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS MIKE THANK
LIVELY.
I'M A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
GIFFORD LAWCENTER TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE WHERE I DIRECT OUR
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE INITIATIVE.
AND I'M HERE TODAY NOT JUST ON
BEHALF OF GIFFORD'S BUT ALSO A
MUCH BROADER COALITION OF
VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY
ACTIVISTS CITY LEADERS AND
RESEARCHERS.
THAT ARE ALL COMMITTED TO
REDUCING VIOLENCE BY
IMPLEMENTING EVIDENCE BASED AND
COMMUNITY DRIVEN STRATEGIES THAT
ARE MOST IMPACTED NEIGHBORHOODS
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN RECENT YEARS CITIES LIKE
OAKLAND RICHMAN AND LOS ANGELES
HAVE SEEN ENORMOUS REDUCTIONS IN
SERIOUS VIOLENCE AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO SCALE THAT SUCCESS TO
MORE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
THIS YEAR WE'VE PUSHED HARD FOR
FUNDING INCREASES THE CALVET UP
WHICH IS THE STATE'S ONLY
DEDICATED SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
THIS TYPE OF ON THE GROUNDWORK.
AND WE THANK YOU AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE FOR
HEARING OUR CLL AND FOR
CHOOSING TO INVEST AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM.
NOW THAT WE HAVE COMMITTED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE HAVING THE
MAXIMUM IMPACT POSSIBLE AND THIS
BILL AB SIX IN A THREE AT CHIEF
THREE IMPORTANT GOALS.
THE FIRST IS THAT IT PLACES THE
CALVET PROGRAM IT TO STATUTE
MAKING THIS A MORE PERMANENT
FIXTURE OF CALIFORNIA'S VIOLENCE
PREVENTION INFRASTRUCTURE.
SEC YET THE BILL WOULD REMOVE
OUTDATED AWARD CAPS THAT ARE
HOLD OVER FROM PRIOR YEARS WHEN
THE PROGRAM WAS MUCH SMALLER.
I PRESIDENT AWARD CABS ARE AT
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER GRAND T. OVER TWO YEAR
PERIOD WHICH WOULD FOR FIRST BSE
SEE WHICH IS THE AGENCY THAT
ADMINISTERS CALVET -- TO DILUTE
THIS PROGRAM ESSENTIALLY BY
DISTRIBUTING A LARGE NUMBER OF
SMALLER GRANTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
COUNTY I. P. EXECUTIVE STEERING
COMMITTEE TO SET A MORE
REASONABLE CAP SO THAT
APPLICANTS IF THEY CHOOSE CAN
APPLY FOR MORE FUNDING DEPENDING
ON LOCAL NEED AND CONDITIONS.
THIRD THIS BILL FOCUSES ON
CALVET THIS BILL FOCUSES CALVET
TO RESOURCES I'M COMMUNITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AT THE
HIGHEST RISK OF EXPOSURE TO
VIOLENCE.
WE KNOW BASED ON DATA AND
STUDIES THAT VIOLENCE IS
EXTREMELY CLUSTERED IN A SMALL
NUMBER OF PLACES AND IMPORTANTLY
IN ANY GIVEN CITY THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SERIOUS VIOLENCE IS
CARRIED OUT BY A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
APPLICANTS TO PROPOSE PLANS AND
STRATEGIES TO WORK WITH THOSE
ROUTE HIGHEST RISK OF ENGAGING
IN VIOLENCE.
THEY'RE JUST TWENTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT COMBINED
CONSTITUTE MORE THAN HALF OF THE
HOMICIDES THAT ARE EXPERIENCED
IN THE STATE EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
AND IT IS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING THE
BULK OF OUR RESOURCES.
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
SUCCESSFUL STATE WIDE VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS SUCH AS
CONNECTICUT NEW YORK AND
MASSACHUSETTS ARE FOLLOWING THIS
EXACT SAME STRUCTURE.
THIS BILL WOULD BRING OUR CAL B.
I. P. PROGRAM IN LINE WITH BEST
PRACTICES FROM OTHER STATES.
WHICH HAVE RATES OF GUN
HOMICIDES MUCH MUCH LOWER THAN
CALIFORNIA.
SO VIOLENCE IS IMPOSING AN
INCREDIBLE COST IN TERMS OF
HUMAN LIVES BUT ALSO AN ECONOMIC
COST OF LAW ENFORCEMENT HEALTH
CARE COST IT CETERA.
AND INVESTING IN SCALING UP
PROVEN SOLUTIONS IN OUR MOST
IMPACTED CITIES IS A VERY SMART
DECISION.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP INSURE THAT
THESE RESOURCES HAVE THE LARGEST
POSSIBLE IMPACT AND SAVE THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF LIVES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ON BEHALF OF GIFFORD'S IN
OUR COUNTY IP COALITION WE URGE
YOU TO PASS THIS BILL THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOU CAN JUST COME UP TO THE MIKE.
HELLO KATHY BURKE WITH THE
HEALTH OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
EMILY ALL VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CRYSTAL OF LOTTO VOLUNTEER OF
MONSTER INACTION NATURE OF YOUR
FROM ALAMEDA TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CAL RIDERS FROM HOMES DEMAND
ACTION.
IN THE ELK GROVE I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MARY LOU ROSADO.
I AM FROM MOMS DEMAND ACTION IN
YOLO COUNTY.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CYNTHIA SHELL AND I'M A
SUPPORTER OF MOST MEN ACTION FOR
GUN SENSE AN AMERICANIZED FOR
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AMY HOW COME A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DELEGATES MOMS DEMAND ACTION
SUPPORT.
KAREN'S AN AUTO I'M HERE WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION FROM WEST
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CASSANDRA WET STONE WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
ADAM KEVIN ON BEHALF OF EVERY
TIME FOR GUN SAFETY IN SUPPORT.
FEELING FOR THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
IN TRUMP SUPPORT.
RIGHT ANY OTHERS.
OKAY LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO GOT A LOVELY STREET CURA
BILLS WITHOUT OPPOSITION GOOD TO
KNOW -- LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY --
COMMONSENSE SENATOR MORE LIKE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ARM.
YES IT ON GOVERNMENT COVER.
SO ON THE BUDGET DISTRIBUTED
MEDIA.
THE BUDGET CONFERENCE I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'VE
ALREADY SET ASIDE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP ME OUT YOU'RE
SAYING YOU AYE CODIFIED BUT?
YOU READY GOT THE FUNDING AND
THERE'S ALREADY A PROCESS SO
WHAT ARE MY BUT I JUST MISSION I
THINK ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
THINGS THIS WOULD LIFT THE CAPS
WHICH IS IMPORTANT.
IN TERMS OF HOW THESE
ORGANIZATIONS -- IN IN TERMS OF
THE ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE
ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATIONS ON
THE GROUND THERE DOING THE WORK --
THE CAP WHICH IS AS MENTIONED
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
OVER TWO YEARS IS ABOUT TWO
FIFTY YEAR -- WE WANT MORE
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT IF WE INVEST
MORE RESOURCES -- WE CAN DO THAT
SO I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST CRITICAL COMPONENTS
AND JUST TO PUT THIS IN STATUTE
SO THAT WE CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
THIS PROGRAM YEAR AFTER YEAR.
AND I'M SURE IT WILL INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL BUDGET ASKS -- AS IT
ALWAYS IS -- BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE REALLY INVESTING IN THIS
PROGRAM.
SO A TRIP TO THE CAP IS THE IS
THE ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHANGES.
TO OVER MY WORDS VERY ARE YOU
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE THEY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL -- WERE WORKING WITH
THEM THE THE BOARD OF STATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS THERE THE
ONE ADMINISTRATION -- ON THE CAP
QUESTION TALKING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO TO RECTIFY THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
AND SIR MORE LIKE BY MY DAD ON
THE AUTHOR REFERENCED
ORGANIZATIONS BUT IN FACT CITIES
ARE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR THIS
FUNDING AND GIVEN THE OBVIOUS --
LARGE DIFFERENCES IN POPULATION
OF OUR VERY CITIES.
A ARM IF THE CITY OF LA WERE TWO
ONE ENGAGE IN THEY ARE ENGAGING
IN A VERY ROBUST.
OF GUN VIOLENCE REDUCTION
PROGRAM.
THAT MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE -- FOR
SAID TO GRANT.
THEY WOULD HAVE THE SAME CAP AS
OF FOR EXAMPLE AND MY CITY OF
BERKELEY WHICH IS A HUNDRED AND
TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE VERSUS A TEN
MOUNT MILLION POPULATION CITY SO
I THINK THAT.
IT.
THE CHANGE TO LIFT THE CAP IS --
AT MAKES SENSE IN TERMS OF WHO
WHO IS ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY FOR FUNDING -- THE ONLY
OTHER THING I WOULD NOTICE THAT
THE FUNDING THAT IS SECURED. FOR
CALVET BEEN THIS BUDGET WHICH IS
THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET IS A
ONE YEAR ONLY.
SO -- I THINK BY.
PUTTING I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL BY PUTTING.
THIS IN THE STATUTE WELL IT DOES
NOT GUARANTEE THERE'S NOT AN
APPROPRIATION ASSOCIATED.
IT POTENTIALLY RAISES THE
PROFILE OF THE PROGRAM AND
POTENTIALLY GIVES IT A BETTER
SHOT AT ON GOING SUPPORT IN
BUDGETARY ACTIONS NOT A
GUARANTEE.
BUT POTENTIALLY.
ALRIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION.
OKAY WE'VE GOT A MOTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE -- LET'S DO A
ROLL CALL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD JACKSON
MITCHELL MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
I WITH THE BILL I AM WILL BE ON
CALL WHEN OUR ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL COME BACK THEIR OWN
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES AND NOW I
THINK IT'S OUR FINAL AUTHOR.
HEY FINALLY WE ALWAYS WE ALWAYS
SAVE THE BEST FOR LAST I KNOW
DON'T YOU LOVE THIS.
GOD DOES SAVE ONE LOOK BACK AT
IT DOES SAVE ONE'S BACK -- I
DON'T HAVE A A STICK ANYWAY WE
ARE NOW GOING TO HEAR ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- SIX YEARS AGO
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS GAINED
THE RIGHT TO A DRIVER'S LICENSE
SO THAT THEY COULD BE LAW
ABIDING DRIVERS AN EFFORT AIMED
AT PROVIDING US ALL PEACE OF
MIND ON THE ROAD.
NOW FEAR IS UNDERMINING THE AB
SIXTY LICENSE PROGRAM RECENT
NEWS REPORTS HAVE UNCOVERED THAT
AYE ACE HAS BEEN ACCESSING STATE
RUN DATABASES CONTAINING
INFORMATION ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
WITH LICENSES THAT WERE MADE
AVAILABLE UNDER AB.
SIXTY THESE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
POLICY TACTICS ARE CONCERNING WE
NEED TO PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN
PROHIBITS CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM MAKING
THEIR DATABASES AVAILABLE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT ONE FORSMAN AGENCIES
WITH ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA LAW.
ENFORCEMENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM CLASS ARE ALLOWED TO
ACCESS INFORMATION FROM DRIVERS
LICENSES OR IDENTIFICATION CARD
RECORDS INCLUDING NAME DATE OF
BIRTH RESIDENTS AND OR MAILING
ADDRESS AND PHOTOS.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN UP
HOLDEN PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S CORE
VALUES AND THAT'S WHY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
TODAY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSES WITH CHAIR OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS HI HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT HAS EVOLVED FROM
HUMANE ENFORCEMENT TO AUTOMATED
ENFORCEMENT.
WE SAW PEAK -- NGUYEN SECURE
COMMUNITIES WAS CREATED DURING
THE BUSH ERA TO RUN FOR YOUR
PRINTS TO ANYONE WHO CAME IN
CONTACT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITHOUT IMMIGRATION.
ALL THIS AUTOMATED SYSTEM ARE
RESULTING IN -- THEIR RELIGION
OF TRUST BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE AUTOMATED SYSTEM INCLUDED
THIRD PARTY ENTITIES IN WHICH
THERE IS NO NEED. FOR ICE TO
PRODUCE A WARRANT TO ACCESS THAT
INFORMATION SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SIXTY
CHIRLA HAS.
HER CASES AND BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION THE DMV DMV STAFF OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD NO CRIMINAL
OFFENSE JUST AN IMMIGRATION.
DEPORTATION ORDER ARE AN
INTERACTION WITH C. P. ICE WHO
ARE OFTEN OBTAINED A DRIVER'S
LICENSE.
AND ICE HAS SHOWN UP TO THEIR
HOUSE FOR EXAMPLE.
GIVE ROLE WAS IN REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS -- WAS A FORMER
RESIDENT OR WEST COVINA APPLY
FOR ANY BE SIXTY DRIVER'S
LICENSE USING HIS REAL NAME IN
ISRAEL INFORMATION WEEKS LATER.
HOMELAND SECURITY INVESTIGATION --
ISIS SHOWED UP TO HIS HOUSE THIS
BILL BUILDS UPON THE PROTECTIONS
OF AB SIXTY WITHOUT INTERFERING
THE CURRENT DATABASE THAT ICE.
AGE ASIDE AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE AT
THEIR DISPOSAL FOR THE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
OUR LET'S SEE IF THERE'S OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MANAGER MEMBER DAN FILLS OUT ON
BEHALF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DA'S OFFICE THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE.
THAT THE TRUST THAT WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED WITH THEM --
COMMITTEES REMAINS.
IN THIS FIRST REPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OTHERS.
ANDREA RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
RIGHT ANY OTHERS.
SEE IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I THINK YOU ALL CAN
STAND THE DIVORCE I THINK
THERE'S ONLY ONE IN THE CONCERT
RIGHT THERE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COURCELLES ALONG BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION -- LET ME JUST START
BY SAYING SURE OF DO NOT
ENGAGING IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
NOR DO THEY WISH -- TO OUR
OBJECTION TO THIS BILL IS IS
MERELY ONE I THINK OF SCOPE BAD
THE BILL.
EFFECTIVELY PRECLUDES -- ACCESS
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT DATABASES WE
UNDERSTAND FROM MATERIALS FROM
THE PROPONENTS AS WELL AS THE
AUTHOR STATEMENT THAT THIS
LARGELY REVOLVES AROUND.
ACCESS TO DMV RECORDS AND BY A
SUSPECT THERE MIGHT BE A WAY TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
WITHOUT.
TOTALLY CLOSING THE DOOR FOR
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ACCESS
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INFORMATION. FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT INFORMATION SO AGAIN
WHO IS NOT A DESIRE ON THE PART
OF SHERIFF'S TO SHARE --
INFORMATION FOR IMMIGRATION
PURPOSES -- BUT UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE ARE.
NEEDS AND REASONS WHY FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD NEED TO
ACCESS INFORMATION ABOUT
DANGEROUS PEOPLE IRRESPECTIVE OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS -- AND SO --
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVA THANK
YOU.
OKAY.
HEART ANY OTHER.
OPPOSITION EARN ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
ALL RIGHT AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO A CLOSER AND I
HAVEN'T HAD THE CHANCE DON'T
SHARE SATIN BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THEM THIS IS BEEN
FRUSTRATING FOR US I THINK
TRYING TO COME UP WITH THE BILL --
TO TO REALLY NARROWLY FOCUS IT
ON WHAT WE KNOW HAS HAPPENED
WITHOUT EXPLANATION FROM ICE WE
KNOW -- THAT ICE HAS SHOWN UP ON
THE DOORSTEP OF OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO OTHERWISE LAW ABIDING
INDIVIDUALS WHO -- ARE HERE WITH
THEIR AB SIXTY LICENSE
INFORMATION AND PICTURE.
THAT WE KNOW -- WHEN WE PASS
THIS BILL WE TOLD PEOPLE IF YOU
HAVEN'T COMMITTED A CRIME YOU'RE
NOT THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE USED
AGAINST YOU?
SO THERE IS A LOT OF CONFUSION
IN THE COMMUNITY WE WANT PEOPLE
TO BE DRIVING AWFULLY IT'S GOOD
FOR ALL OF US RIGHT.
ARE ONLY IN AND WE'VE HAD
MULTIPLE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS
WE COULD GO OUT AND TELL OUR
COMMUNITIES DON'T GO GET THIS
LICENSE I MEAN THAT'S NOT WE
WILL BE GOING BACKWARDS IN
SAFETY I THINK -- AND I THINK
ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS WILL
BE GOING BACKWARDS ON THE SAFETY
ISSUE -- ICE OF COURSE ONE TELL
US EXACTLY HOW THEY GOT THIS
INFORMATION -- DMV HAS TOLD US
THAT IT IS NOT DIRECTLY FROM DMV
BUT THEY HAVE TOLD US WHERE THIS
INFORMATION GOES AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO CREATE A BILL -- THAT
PREVENTS ICE FROM FROM GETTING
THAT DMV PHOTO AND INFORMATION --
FROM A DATABASE OF AT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A NAME AND THEY CAN
SEARCH THAT DATABASE SO WHAT.
I UNDERSTAND AND I AM AT MY
FRUSTRATION I HOPE I DON'T SOUND
TOO FRUSTRATED I.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE PEOPLE SAYING
THAT'S NOT YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THAT'S TO BROADER DOESN'T WORK
THAT WAY WILL SOMEBODY TELL ME
HOW IT WORKS.
IN WE WILL.
NARROWLY TAILOR.
THIS BILL TO AVOID THAT RIGHT
NOW WE THINK IF YOU HAVE AN
ACTUAL WARRANT FOR SOMEBODY SO
IF THEY'VE COMMITTED A CRIME%
OKAY YOU CAN SEARCH THE DATABASE
AND YOU UTILIZE.
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE THAT'S IN
THERE TO FIND THE PERSON THIS IS
IF YOU HAVE.
SIMPLY A DEPORTATION ORDER --
THAT YOU CAN'T GO IN AT AS ICE
AND SEARCH THE DATABASE TO COME
UP WITH THEIR CURRENT ADDRESS
AND PICTURE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO AVOID.
FOR OTHERWISE LAW ABIDING IN --
RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA -- SO
WITH THAT IT YOU KNOW I'LL
CONTINUE TO DEFINITELY WORK WITH
THE SHERIFF'S AND ANYONE ELSE
THAT.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE -- BECAUSE
NOBODY SEEMS TO HAVE AN ANSWER
JUST -- PROTEST IN OUR ONLY
OTHER ANSWER I WILL I WILL SAY
AGAIN IS TO GO TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND SAY YOU ARE PUTTING YOURSELF
AT RISK BY GETTING AB SIXTY
LICENSE.
THAT IS NOT GOOD FOR ANY OF US
SO.
RESPECT LAST FROM ABOUT.
THANK YOU -- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THAT WE YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT WE DO NOT WANT TO HAVE.
PEOPLE DRIVING WITHOUT A LICENSE
THEN THAT ALSO IF THEY DO SO
THEN THEY ALSO ARE NO LONGER OF
FIGHTING BY OUR INSURANCE
REQUIREMENT LAWS OR ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS SO IT IS -- THAT THAT
ALONE IS A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE.
AND CERTAINLY I ALSO APPRECIATE
THAT.
IN.
THAT YOU HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
NARROW IT SO THAT IT IS ONLY
COVERING.
THAT IF THERE IS A PERSON WHO
HAS.
COMMITTED A CRIME THAT THERE WAS
STILL ACCESS TO THE DATABASE BUT
IF THIS IS PURELY ACCESS JUST TO
GET -- ADDRESSES ARE SUCH THAT
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO RESTRICT SO I DO
PPRECIATE THAT.
I KNOW THAT YOU'LL BE HAVING
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS TO SEE IF
YOU CAN ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED -- AND I'LL SEE
IF ANYONE ELSE HAS EITHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CENTER MOORLACH HI I'M I'M A
LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
BILL -- BUT I'LL WAIT.
UNTIL LATER I SEE SOME
RESOLUTION WITH THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION -- LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S A MOTION FROM OF IT OKAY
AND BY THAT WAS A CLOSE GREAT.
SO WE WILL DO A ROLL CALL -- AND
THE BILL IS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND GO TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND IF YOU ARE WILLING
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR [inaudible]
THIS.
ALL RIGHT SO -- LET'S DO ROLL
CALL.
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
AYE JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MORALE
[inaudible]
HELLO WIENER.
WE WILL BE HOLDING THE BILL THE
ROLE OF OPEN.
UNTIL WE GET OUR ABSENT MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESENTING.
AND WILL NOW SEE IF WE CAN'T --
GATHER ARE ABSENT MEMBERS SO
THAT WE CAN OPEN THE ROLE ON ALL
THOSE THAT ARE ON THE BILLS THAT
ARE STILL WAITING TO GET THEIR
FULL FIRST.
THROUGH ONCE.
YES CERTAINLY OKAY WE WILL.
GET WELL WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE
ROLE JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
MEMBERS IT NEED TO LEAVE RIGHT
AWAY BUT ARGUED BY SHEER WAS
HERE THE WHOLE TIME SO HE
DOESN'T NEED [inaudible]
OKAY.
GREAT LET'S OPEN THE ROLE.
ITEM TWO EIGHTY ONE SIXTY FIVE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
HI SKINNER AYE BRADFORD ALL
RIGHT BRADFORD AYE.
AB ONE SIXTY FIVE IS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM THREE EIGHTY TWO
FORTY THREE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO TO ONE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE MITCHELL WIENER.
THEY ARE THAT'S ARM STAYS ON
CALL AB.
TWO FORTY THREE ITEM FOR WHICH
IS CONSENT CALENDAR SKINNER.
FIVE SKINNER AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
RIGHT CONSENT CALENDARS OUT
[inaudible]
EIGHTY FOUR THREE THREE D.
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
BOTH THREE TO ZERO SKINNER.
FIGHT SKINNER AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON.
JACKSON HI WIENER [inaudible]
THIS CALL -- AB FOR THREE THREE
WILL REMAIN ON CALL [inaudible]
BRADFORD I AB FOR THREE THREE
WILL STILL REMAIN ON CALL
BECAUSE WE HAVE ONE MISSING
MEMBERS.
ITEM ELEVEN SB SIX SIX THREE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO TO ZERO SKINNER.
HI SKINNER AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL WIENER.
BRADY B. SIX SIX THREE WILL
REMAIN ON CALL FOR TO ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
SEVEN NINE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
ONE ONE SKINNER.
BY SKINNER AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE WIENER -- AB EIGHT SEVEN
NINE WILL REMAIN ON CALL.
ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
ONE ZERO SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER AYE BRADFORD.
[inaudible]
WIENER. THIRTY NINE SEVENTEEN
WILL ALSO REMAIN A CALL.
ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE SIX
FIVE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS
THREE TO ONE SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HIGH.
I'M AB NINE SIX FIVE IS ABOUT.
FIVE TO ONE ITEM FIFTEEN AB ONE
THOUSAND NINE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
FOR TO WIND SKINNER HI SKINNER
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I AB. ONE ZERO ZERO
NINE IS OUT.
SIX TO ONE I AM SIXTEEN THEM AB
ONE ONE ONE SEVEN MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
TO JUDICIARY.
MY APOLOGIES I HAVE A PROBLEM --
WITH LET'S MAKE SURE WE HAVE IT.
IT IS OKAY.
MY APOLOGIES.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO ZERO
SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE.
I WILL HOLD THAT -- AB ONE
SEVENTEEN OPEN ONE ONE SEVEN ONE
ONE YEAH YEAH WHATEVER. SEVEN
SEVENTEEN I AM SEVENTY NEEDS AND
MOTION OKAY SO WE HAVE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO IT'S DO PASSED
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION LET'S DO THE ROLL CALL
SOMEONE.
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE MORE
LOCK.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
AYE JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MORALE.
AROUND AND WIENER.
RIGHT WE WILL -- LEAVE THAT -- A
ROLL CALL OPEN ON AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO ITEM.
EIGHTEEN AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ZERO BRADFORD NO.
THREE JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
WIENER.
ALREADY BE SIXTEEN OH THREE WILL
REMAIN ON CALL ALSO.
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN BUSH IS THE PAST TO
DIGEST MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MITCHELL WIENER.
I'M.
SORRY WHAT [inaudible]
YES.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN REMAINS
ON CALL [inaudible]
WE JUST [inaudible]
WIENER
.
YES REMEMBER BILL FORTY THROUGH
[inaudible]
THERE WERE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
THE FEDERAL
-- SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WILL RECESS.
UNTIL.
THE CAUCUSES CLOSE SO IT WILL BE
WE WILL COME BACK IN THIS ROOM --
I'M NOT GONNA PUT EXPLICIT TIME
BUT IT WILL BE APPROXIMATELY ONE
THIRTY IT MAY BE A SLIGHTLY
BEFORE BUT AT THAT POINT WE WILL
RE OPEN THE ROLE FOR THE
REMAINING BILLS THAT WE HAVE ON
CALL.
BUT AT THE MOMENT WE ARE
RECESSED UNTIL CAUCUS CONCLUDES
WORK SAFETY NOW IS OUT OF
RECESSED CENTER PUBLIC SAFETY
AND WE'RE RE OPENING THE RULES
ON A FEW BILLS.
WE ARE GOING TO RE OPEN ITEM
EIGHTY BEFORE THREE THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WIENER WIENER HIGH RIGHT AB
THREE FOUR THREE THREE IS NOW
OUT.
SEVEN ZERO WE WILL NOW RE OPENED
AB -- EIGHT SEVEN NINE ITEM
TWELVE ITEM TWELVE EVE BE EIGHT
SEVEN NINE GIPSON.
PARTY ABSENT MEMBERS SERVICE
FOUR TO ONE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
AB EIGHT SEVEN NINE IS NOW OUT
FIVE ZERO FOR FIVE ONE SKEWS ME.
FIVE ONE THREE I WILL NOW RE
OPENED -- AB ONE ONE SEVEN WHICH
IS ONE ONE ONE SEVEN WHICH IS
ITEM NUMBER. SIXTEEN CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX TWO ZERO WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
AB ONE ONE ONE SEVEN IS NOW OUT.
SEVEN ZERO AND WE HAVE.
THE WILL OF FOR WITH OTHER BILLS.
BUT WE HAVE TO WAIT TILL OUR
OTHER MISS MEMBER COMES HERE --
SHOULD I TAX -- I TOOK CENTER IN
SYRACUSE OWNER WAY
WE WILL START.
WE HAVE A NINE ONE SEVEN NO NO
OKAY SHE GOT IT ALL.
TO FORTY SHE WAS ON SORRY I'M
NOT ALWAYS OKAY SO EITHER WE
WILL START.
WITH ITEM THREE AB TWO FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM
LONGER DUFF ABSENT MEMBERS TURN
VOTE IS THREE TO ONE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
RIGHT THERE BILLS NOW OUT FIVE
ONE THAT IS AB TWO FOUR THREE
OUT.
FIVE ONE OKAY WE'LL GO NEXT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HE'LL GO NEXT -- TO WE IS THAT
IT.
ITEM.
THIRTEEN WHAT ABOUT CUNNINGHAM I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX SIX THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
MOTION WAS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LET'S CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CAN FIND.
CURRENT LOTUS FIVE ZERO MITCHELL
HI MITCHELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ALRIGHT SO -- EIGHTY SIX SIX
THREE IS NOW OUT. FIVE ZERO
THIRTEEN THE FIVE ZERO AB SEVEN
SIX SIX THREE SEVEN ZERO AB.
SIX SIX THREE SEVEN ZERO KERN.
ITEM.
THIRTEEN I WILL NOW DO ITEM
THIRTEEN AB STE NINE SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE TWO ZERO MITCHELL --
I'M NUMBER SORRY.
THIRTEEN NINE ONE SEVEN MITCHELL
AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
OKAY EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN IS
NOW OUT FIVE ZERO WILL GO TO AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO ITEM SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA IT IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE THREE TO ONE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE WE REMEMBER SALAS.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE FIVE
TWO ZERO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ALL RIGHT AB TWO OF NINE FOUR IS
NOW OUT.
SEVEN ZERO AND WILL GO TO A. B. --
ITEM TWENTY AB SIXTEEN OH THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS -- DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE FIVE ZERO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
FOR AB SIX ZERO THREE IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO HOUSTON I LAST BUT
NOT LEAST IS ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN GONZALEZ.
DO PASSED TO JUDICIARY CURRENT
VOTE THREE TO ONE MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
IN NINETEEN THE BILL IS NOW OUT.
FIVE ONE YEAH OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO GO IN ORDER THEM.
YEAH.
AND THEN HOW ABOUT -- ITEM.
FIVE THE OLD BALL AND ITEM.
SIX ALL.
OF THEM -- AND ANNOUNCER ITEM
FIFTEEN THAT I'VE LOOK SAFETY
AND THE MEETING IS NOW.
ADJOURNED